you got to show up number one rule of
success show up see Rambo he showed up
okay Corleone showed up Die Hard boy
showed up and of course Burt Reynolds
Arnold Schwarzenegger these guys showed
up you got to show up this was given to
me thought leadership Forward Thinking
strategy for the 10th Annual Global
family office investment summary in
Dubai I showed up I spoke they gave me
this beautiful gift most people don't
show up showing up it don't mean you got
to the office you understand it doesn't
mean you came to work for me showing up
means I show up I've been showing up
since I was 25 years old man before that
I wasn't showing up I was showing off I
was acting a fool being a fool High
School I didn't show up I went to class
I never showed up my body went in the
room see showing up doesn't mean you got
there showing up means you got there
means you show up for the class you show
up for the homework means you keep
showing up to the next level and I hear
a lot of people talking about showing up
you know showing up is not everything
let me tell you something showing up as
one 100 percent of success you can't
keep showing up as the old you you got
to show up as the new you hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because as a young entrepreneur I
struggle to keep my business going I had
no friends I had no mentors I had no
role models and the thing that saved me
was learning from the success stories of
famous entrepreneurs and in their
stories I got motivation and I also got
strategies for what I could do to grow
my business and not stay stuck and I
still need their stories of motivation
today so today let's get some incredible
motivation from the one and only Grant
Cardone enjoy
I'm more of a doer than I'm a dreamer
okay I don't really dream I don't really
I mean I do I've written all this stuff
up all one day I'm on a jet and I'm
gonna have a bunch of Apartments but I
wasn't dreaming very big
my apartment Target was like a thousand
units okay I thought if I ever had 1 000
units that I would be that would have
been the Pinnacle we owned 12 000 and
I'll probably buy that many this year
wow but but all this has happened
because of doing I remember walking in a
room I was in the Oak Oak Brook
Marriott in Oakbrook Illinois and I
walked in a room and it was empty and
there was a chair set up for like 200
people I said one day I'm going to speak
to a full room with 200 people sitting
in the room well
we've done 35 000 person events I was
there yeah so so I had never dreamed as
big
as I've accomplished but I do like I'm a
doer like anything that I can do I do
um the phone calls down to grind you
know Granny kind of terrible little
things like taking out the trash okay
that is a form of doing I there's no
work that I won't do
and because I know I'll take out the
trash or pick up the boards or help the
guy out or whatever it is right because
I know I can do those things I could I
can do the bigger things too this is a
cycle of a business
I'm gonna take one little idea and I'm
gonna turn it into a business eighty
thousand dollars a year to go to
Stanford Harvard MIT or Yale and never
learn this process this is a true story
I'm gonna write the millionaire booklet
watch what I do I'm driving home from
downtown Miami it was a charity event
and I gave some money to help this
charity that night and I'm driving home
and Elena's like I'm so proud of you
grant you did such a good thing tonight
I get home and I'm like I'm gonna write
a book tonight how to become a
millionaire most of you would sit down
and start writing the book what I did
next was write an offer
I'm like okay this book is going to be
uh 1995. I'm going to sell it for 9.95
it's going to be a pre-order I'm
literally calling Sherry at midnight hey
give me a give me a landing site right
now we're going to call it the
millionaire book and Sherry's like you
can't write a book you're under contract
with penguin random right now and and
they get your next book I said did we
agree to a book or a booklet she's like
a book book I said good don't call it
the millionaire book call it the
millionaire booklet okay if that don't
work we'll call it the millionaire
pamphlet okay let them sue me later in
the mind the mind says oh I'm gonna
write a book and you want to think you
need to finish a product I don't think I
need to finish a product I need to start
selling books okay now I need to Market
this book well Grant the book's not
finished right now okay ain't nobody
coming to your house at 12 30 at night
to get the book I start advertising
money I got a book so you guys won't do
that
you're like but I don't have a book I
got a book I got time nobody expects to
get the book in an instant I had a
landing page up see this landing page we
added the video the next day so idea
offer Market notice I haven't written
anything now I'm going to sell it I'm
gonna close the fifth step will be to
deliver a service so what am I going to
do here right here you gotta write your
book okay I had this idea at 11 o'clock
at night at 11 20 I think we got our
first order 20 minutes after it and then
I go online and say hey guys if you
could help me translate my new book into
Arabic Hebrew can you please do this for
me and I'll give you credit for the
translation 38 languages in 30 days and
I paid a whopping zero more importantly
I got the word out on this new book now
I gotta write the book by one o'clock in
the morning 1am the book was finished
now you're like man how do you write a
book so fast because I was selling books
fast honesty integrity and ethics they
have power I commit to People by accept
their money the moment people start
giving me money I'm like oh I gotta
deliver now if you're a good person you
should have good things coming your way
if you don't have good things coming
your way and you're a good person that's
because something in your business cycle
is broken nothing's really happened by
the way in these recessions nothing
really changed it's just an illusion
that somehow oh my God there's no money
now now the money's still there
nothing's really changed except
everybody's mindset everybody still has
to eat they still have to wear clothes
they still have to travel they still
want to have sex and procreate and have
fun and go to the movies and everybody
wants to do the same stuff you still got
eight billion people on the planet
growing every day the the thing is
there's fewer people going for it this
is what I always say man there's there's
a an abundance amount of money on planet
Earth and a shortage of people going
after it and this is the perfect time
this is it go all out bro this is it
because what happens if you 10x your
efforts for for just short periods of
time maybe six or eight or nine months
and start building out a new network of
people what happens is
people are going to back out
and you're going to look up you'll be
like there's only three or four of us on
the field
like there's only going to be a handful
of people playing the game everybody
else is just just oh I'm grateful you
know we're we're better off than the
pakistanians and the Palestinians in the
in the Cubans and the it's all you're
always comparing yourself to some third
world country that's not developed this
is what people do all the time by the
way okay uh there's some Village in
Africa where you know they don't have
running water I hear this story all the
time these people you ever been to
Africa we have food you know you don't
even know what you're talking about
you're comparing you could always find
somebody worse off to compare yourself
to when what you should be doing instead
looking up is setting an example for all
the people that are below you or side of
you they're suffering and say no man we
should be expanding and have prosperity
in all times especially in tough times
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all of the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there most people just simply have the
wrong target
most small businesses in America Break
Even or lose money because they have
their own Target they're just like I
just want to make 70 grand out of my
business I want to own my business I
want to be the boss the boss of what
you know and so so first thing we do is
fix the target what is the target this
reset is going to be create massive
opportunities this is where wealth is
created in very short periods of time
anybody can get this well because the
big money is going to sideline okay
that's the sideline because it's public
a little more complicated but they're
public so they have to be careful okay
and you don't you need to take risks
right now you guys are just getting
started
you're not going to start right here
you're going to start down there okay
probably in another city another town I
grew up in Lake Charles Louisiana no
money raised by a single mother I was in
debt at 25 years old the first thing
that I had to do in my life was not
learn a new skill
first thing I had to do to get my life
moving in the right direction was
self-development
it is vital it was vital for me that I
improved myself and I could start
depending upon me I had to show up every
day with some rituals some disciplines
and start getting myself to trust me not
trust others but trust myself to do the
right thing every day one of the things
that I started doing was beating the Sun
up every morning
I'm gonna beat that son up every morning
so that I have the discipline and the
control of over my life
so I knew hey before that thing pops I'm
gonna pop I'm gonna get out of bed
depend on myself get up at the same time
every day and for me that time
regardless of where I was was beat that
son up no matter where I am I'm gonna
beat that thing up so it gives me a
sense of control over my own life second
thing I had to start cleaning up my life
and my friends and my environment when I
was younger between 15 and 25 I was
doing crazy stuff in my life
wasting my weekends I have the same
weekends are for the week
I was drinking
fooling around with a bunch of bad
things bad people making poor choices
at 25 years old I cleaned it all up quit
going to those places quit using those
things quit hanging out with people that
did not have ethics and discipline in
their life that weren't committed to the
same things that I was
I wanted to build something in my life I
wanted to become someone and to do that
to become someone in the eyes of the
world the first thing I had to do was
become someone I could depend on so put
some things together three or four
things you can do every day to start the
day
kick start your day get going in your
day to give you a sense of respect for
yourself accomplishment for yourself
look just beating that scent up every
morning gives me the sense of
accomplishment that I did what I said
said I was going to do that I woke up
when I said I would wake up and I start
building respect for myself start
believing in myself so that I can go out
into the world and maybe maybe maybe
today maybe today when I go into this
meeting that I'm dressed for maybe
they'll believe in me as much as I
believe in me and that'll show up in a
contract a deal maybe even some money
beat the Sun up never give up on your
financial goals until you achieve your
financial goals there's people in this
room folks that are going to be worth
billions of dollars
there's a billionaire in this room right
now I guarantee you it could be two or
three up
billionaires in the making right here
okay questioning who's it going to be
now if somebody in this room how many
believe this if somebody in this
roommate decision I'm going to put
together a billion dollars how many
believe that's possible
everybody in the room believes it's
possible you might not think it's
possible for you but you know it's
possible which means what the money's
available
would you would you do good things with
that billion dollars
okay you know that about yourself you
don't know about the guy sitting next to
you
you know that about yourself
so you know somebody could do it and you
know if you did it you do good things
with it right
so go do it man because the money's out
there there's plenty and I grew up with
a little uh five uh four foot 11 uh
Italian lady that knew nothing about
money she just knew hold on clip coupons
save your money how many are brought up
like that Penny saved is
and he earned
save for a
see you were brought up the same way I
was eat all your
eat all your food if you don't eat it
all save it put it in the refrigerator
right some of you got you got food in
your refrigerator right now three and
four five days old
you have you have no intention eating it
some of you got you got like an eighth
of a bagel left from five days ago
right now you're like it's in there
right now you got you got you got ice
cream in your in your freezer that's
like six months old
it's expired twice
it's got that much frost on it but you
got one bite left
I know it's still good you tell your
kids this too you pass on the same
to your kids eat all your food
eat all your food eat all your food and
then you wonder why we got obesity
problems in America
we live in a country that's rich and the
people have scarcity in their minds what
is a mindset or belief that you have
that you feel most of the time people
disagree with you on
well I think
a lot I'm a positive person and I'm not
okay this has nothing to do with
positivity or motivation
uh I I'm not I'm not like
you know Mr beat my chest I'm excited
and I'm gonna I'm gonna see myself
through this because I'm going to will
myself through it no I'm not going to do
that like I'm going to do something
what I'm going to do is do something I'm
going to make a call I'm going to send
out an email I'm going to follow that up
I'm going to build a team that can do
the same thing like I am going to win on
action
and it doesn't mean it's it doesn't mean
I'm gonna outwork you
I'm going to out result you
so and I'm not trying to out result you
by the way I'm just like I need to I
need to get results in the marketplace
so I remember uh Gary vaynerchuk was in
my studio once and he was telling me
he's like I'll outwork you I'm like bro
you I mean we just met it you don't know
me I don't know you I don't know what
your work ethic is I don't know what you
do and there's no way you can know
whether you outwork me or not and by the
way it doesn't even matter
what matters is do we get results and so
what we've been successful with this
whole 10x thing is about hey I am going
to set a Target
10 times higher than what I need for
myself and I'm going to do whatever I
have to do between now and the
attainment of that Target to to get that
that is not a mindset it is a decision
but it's not some positivity thing or
enthusiasm like I think people mistake
that I think that's what that's to
answer your question how can I own real
estate control real estate use the cash
I have in the bank to buy a piece of
real estate and have enough tenants pay
me a check every month
I didn't do it the way my uncle did it
my uncle did it one house at a time I
did it 100 units at a time my first deal
was 38 units my second deal was 48 units
my third deal was 90 units now we don't
even look at deals outside we we that
size we look at deals 400 units 500
units now why am I telling you this and
what should you take away from this
okay my first real estate deal was one
house I bought one house
I rented it and as soon as they moved
out I had problems I had to sell the
house just like my mom had to sell the
house so the first thing I want you to
know is this not all real estate makes
you money this piece of real estate
right here this guy paid 19 million
maybe 20 million bucks to build this
house he's going to sell it for 16
million dollars okay I come here I abuse
the damn place for two or three weeks
paid a guy 150 or 300 grand for two
weeks or three weeks that we stay here
and I walk away okay he gets income from
one person or eight people a year eight
people nine people maybe 10 people a
year maybe 12 people maybe he rents it
every week
but he won't do that every year because
if it doesn't snow he won't run it
don't buy single family homes when
somebody's not in it you got to make the
paycheck you got to pay the check okay
when I rent when I buy 100 units or 40
units or 30 units okay my first deal was
38 units I never had less than 34 of
those 38 units rented never did I have
less than 34 out of the 38 units rented
which was enough money to pay the pay
the the the note at the bank to pay for
the roof to be fixed to pay the paint
the tenants termites the toilets the
classified ads the problems my mama told
me one day she's like you don't want to
get in real estate people are going to
be calling you at midnight I'm like I
wish somebody would call me I've been
busting my ass my whole damn life so
somebody would call me God damn if
somebody would call me that means
they're paying me or they want to pay me
so what you gonna do
see your parents have half of everything
right
if they're millionaires they got half of
the equation right they got just enough
money now to say hey I made a bunch of
money I took care of my kids I got them
a college degree we got a nice house and
if I get a divorce it's going to cost me
half that's all the millionaires
nobody tells you that though nobody
tells you that look if you want to make
if you want real Freedom that's what my
dad wanted to provide my mom real
freedom and he never got there because
the week after my dad died my mom had to
sell that house that is not freedom
there was no debt on the house
except for the debt the government puts
on every piece of property in America
property taxes okay and if you can't pay
the property taxes if you can't pay for
the Landscaping if you can't pay to have
the lawn mode the snow to be picked up
and moved okay the pain to be fixed the
cedar the cedar Shake that's going to
fall off this place the roof that's
going to get damaged over some period of
time
if you can't fix all that it's coming
out of your pocket
you're going to be worried when you go
to sleep at night
that's why I buy apartments and Office
Buildings because they provide income
from multiple tenants at one piece of
property it could be a hundred units 200
units 500 units the bigger the bigger
the more units the more protection you
get okay listen to what I'm telling you
that's one unit big nice big ass badass
house right beautiful
okay I'm gonna give them 200 Grand 300
Grand
I'm gonna walk away from this place
okay that one section of the roof over
there could cost him 300 Grand one year
and it will by the way that roof will
not last forever it's got 25-year life
he's got Plumbing issues here he's got
electrical Heating in the floors okay
you know the bridge is going to be a
problem we got water fountains swimming
pools that swimming pool's been at 106
degrees since I got here I'm like Crank
that bad boy all the way up who do you
think's paying the utility bill here not
me
so look not all real estate makes you
money the real estate that makes you
money is the real estate that produces
income every month positive cash flow
cash flow is the Holy Grail
the Holy Grail of all Finance is cash
flow a lot of people watch our videos
they aspire to assets properties Yachts
like this and they should what would be
some of the advice that you would give
them what I would recommend to people is
like number one lock in that success is
important and finances are vital like
you need money and you need a lot of
money number one you need whatever you
think about money you're wrong
and and I'm telling you you're wrong
because you ain't never had any money
or been around anybody with any money so
you can't you shouldn't be making any
decisions about money it's crazy to me
how many people make decisions about
money and never had any and never had
anybody around them that had any money
so most of the people that say money
won't make you happy and it won't do
this and it won't do that I'm like you
don't know anything about money you
should you should just have a clean
slate and say I don't know anything
about money so money is important number
two uh don't lose money you need to
invest in that's guaranteed to make
you money once you earn it man take it
and use it for something that will make
you more money don't keep it don't save
it don't Ira it don't 401K it don't go
buy Gucci and crime shoes don't do any
of that in the beginning okay
yeah no no it's a terrible
you need it you need you need in the
beginning right you need money you need
you don't want to save even three months
of money I would not save that old
about say for a rainy day you
need a 90-day Reserve I wouldn't do any
of that if I was starting over today
I would go out and earn money I would
take all the money invest in something
that paid me a little drip and I'd go
out and earn some more money throw it in
another deal pays me a drip I'm not
talking about stocks I want to convert
paper to an asset that's worth more than
paper how's the cash flow and and so
most of these companies I mean we we're
going to look at a third of the
companies on the entire Stock Exchange
or zombie companies that will never
produce income ever and it'll work
billions of dollars they're garbage and
they're going to go into the dumper and
a lot of people are going to lose a lot
of money gambling on this
so that's what I would tell you man
money's important number two don't lose
it once you get it use it you'll lose it
if you don't use it saving money is is a
is a crazy stupid game you'll never get
wealthy doing that and the third thing
is surround yourself with great people
that are actually moving towards these
same things that are interested in money
and wealth I made the mistake in my
career Jared Jared talked about this it
was I got
I didn't get the engagement right first
I was always engaged I was I've been
again I've been like I've been hungry
the whole time how many hungry in the
room
I've been hungry the whole time I just
hadn't been hungry enough
I should have I should have been
thinking about how do I get thousands of
people working for me
how do I get millions of people knowing
me I didn't know that that's what I was
supposed to be doing I was too worried
about selling him one product so I could
get the money because I was brought up
and we didn't have anything
so for me just to get 200 bucks I was
just doing get 200 bucks over and over
and over again I never thought about
scaling and saying hey how could I get
millions of people to go get 200 bucks
and I get a little piece of it I didn't
I didn't understand the scale I didn't
understand 10x 10x was written for me it
wasn't written for you
10x just solve some of my problems okay
I've been in business 30 years it's only
the last seven that changed my life it
wasn't the first 23. that's not uncommon
by the way okay how old is Amazon
25 years old you would think they're six
or seven years old
okay when I heard they were 25 years old
I'm like I cannot believe that that
means that guy grinded that thing out
for 18 years
and the engagement if you're going to
scale you're gonna you're gonna get
frustrated
can't find the good people
come here they don't really want to work
here how many how many how many of you
in the room respond to resumes
people sent you a resume I want to work
for you you call them back they're like
who are you
right
their problem is your problem everybody
agree their problems are an extension of
your problems
if they can't make this if you can't
make the sale they're not going to be
able to make the sale if you don't
understand advertising and marketing
they're not going to be able to do it
correctly if you don't understand the
accounting department they how can they
possibly understand the accounting
department
foreign
[Music]
I can do something about this situation
there's something I can do to solve this
problem this is the secret of the
successful people this is what I've
committed my life to doing I told my mom
when I was 16 years old one day one day
I'm going to be successful one day one
day I'm going to be successful and one
day I'm gonna help a lot of people I
always say this pay the price today so
you can pay price in the future pay the
price now okay pay the price my buddies
were traveling seeing the world and I
didn't have any of those experiences
I've had people tell me hey you Market
too much
you Market too aggressively
be off your list
my office tells me we hit the list too
much I'm like what's a list for hit the
list
that's what it's for there's a 888
billion people on planet Earth look I've
been ridiculed by my peers my customers
and by competition I've been judged for
working too much wanting too much being
too colorful being inappropriate
insensitive and too out there
I'm trying to figure it out I've been
threatened I've been sued I've been
betrayed by friends I've been ripped off
and I've been copied
30 years 30 Years 18-hour days not eight
hour days not 10 hour days not 12-hour
days 18 hour days
I've been married 15 years to Elena not
one time has she ever said you work too
much not one time
[Music]
she has never said to me what are you
doing getting home so late she knows
what I'm doing
closing deals
I'm taking care of my family I'm trying
to get to 10x levels it's been 30 years
30 years it's probably going to be 30
years for you too doubt uncertainty
insecurities
rejection disappointment judgment it's
gonna be 30 years of it are you willing
to pay the price
are you willing to pay the price
anybody thinks you're going to be
successful without paying that price
you're wrong you know this concept of
work
that the wealthy don't work hard I hear
this constantly you know rich people
don't work hard you know rich people
rich people work smart
that that you got to be kidding right
rich people take all the vacations it's
not true rich people don't take all the
vacation the vacation industry the
vacation industry literally is built off
the middle class not the wealthy
now you might not like this concept but
I'm going to tell you the truth there's
a report that just recently came out
okay one of the most controversial
issues surrounding inequality is work
effort this is a concept of why do the
rich get richer and those people that
don't have or don't have enough keep
sliding down the scale and that's what I
do in these Grant rants is I'm talking
to the middle class about look do you
see it disappearing
it's going away
okay the middle class is getting erased
I came from the middle class and I see
what's happening to it what we used 20
or 30 years ago or 40 years ago to build
a middle class is not working for us
today for instance work hard okay you
see there's this concept that no you
don't need to work hard you just need to
work smart if you work smart you get the
right connections you'll get rich that's
not true this is what it says in this in
this article I found this in the wealth
report do the wealthy work harder than
the rest you might want to Google it a
new study offers evidence that higher
education and therefore higher earning
okay Americans do indeed spend more time
working and less time on Leisure than
poorer income groups okay it's been
validated in this study it says in fact
while incoming inequality inequality may
be growing which it is Leisure
inequality time spent on enjoyment okay
time spent on enjoyment is a growing in
a mirror image what is that saying
people people that are actually making
less money and less wealth are actually
spending more time in Leisure why
because of myths you were taught a myth
you were taught this concept of enjoy my
life you know I gotta enjoy my life I
need to enjoy the day the wealthy don't
think like that I'm telling you the most
successful people don't think about
enjoying life I gotta enjoy they think
about luxury man they think about the
Big Bang they think about the big big
win not the little two-day vacation
what they do is they'll suffer their
whole life so they go go on vacation
later when there's wealth for two and
three months at a time you get it work
hard okay work hard it is a myth that
you're not going to work hard I'm
working harder today than I ever have in
my life
most people only work hard enough
that they're always working you get it
most people only work so hard that they
feel like they're always slaves remember
this anytime you feel like a slave
you've let somebody else be your master
you know what I'm talking about junk
people buy junk people go on vacations
people waste time and they don't have
any money don't let that be you you
should write this down every day this
year is either going to be better for me
or it's going to be worse for me my
marriage is either going to get better
this year or it's going to get worse my
money's going to get better it's going
to get worse my health is going to get
better my health is going to get worse
foreign
will determine whether it's going to be
better or whether it's going to be worse
it will not be up to trump it will not
be up to the Democrats it will not be up
to to something that happens in Iran it
won't be up to the stock market it's up
to you first get rid of the little think
and the old ideas
and the middle class mentality
I'm gonna go to work I'm gonna save some
money I'm gonna put it in the bank I'm
gonna give it to the Man
what's the bait dude the bank doesn't
even keep your money
they hate money
cashes
it's trash
cash is garbage it's pieces the garbage
paper it is only useful when it is used
if you're taking notes
they didn't teach you this in school
this should have been taught basic fifth
grade sixth grade not in not when in
high school or college
cash this is a piece of paper okay it is
a piece of paper it's worthless this is
a piece of paper this actually has more
value this piece of paper right here has
more value than this piece of paper
right here why because one person has
this piece of paper
[Music]
2 000 people have this data
you understand this piece of paper right
here is useless though until it is used
how many of you were taught to say stuff
how many of you got sticky notes and you
save them
you write you write like 17 different
things on one sticky note
I don't I don't want to use the whole
pad
[Music]
I'm gonna make this I'm gonna make this
sticky pad last the rest of my life
okay you got to get rid of the little
thing folks this little think is killing
you let's find out if you got the little
think
how many believe success is a mind game
dude it starts right here you got to fix
this you got to get rid of let's find
out if you've been affected
okay I want you to look at your
refrigerator at home
what's in it
water
nothing's in it it's empty it's very
frugal of you
let's buy a refrigerator keep it empty
okay huh
leftovers what kind of leftovers
what do you got in there
a week old salad he opens the
refrigerator maybe tomorrow
I don't want to throw it away
why
because his mother taught him that
eat all your food eat all your food eat
all your food how many of you brought up
like this three times a day eat it all I
told my wife when I got with her I said
look I'll do anything for you except one
thing
I will not give up on that dream if I
gotta surrender my dream
I'd rather be alone
because if I abandon my dream I'll
abandon you I truly believe that I see
so many people man they give up their
dream for the wife they give up their
dream for the husband they give up their
and then and then the wife and the
husband get together and they have kids
and they give up their dream again
because of the kids and I said the day
we have kids we cannot blame the kids
for not going out for our potential and
our dreams if we ever have kids when we
were getting together and she wasn't
ready to have kids she wasn't even ready
for me and and so I knew she was the
right person for me and I'm like look
I'll give you anything monogamy I'll
never cheat on you I'll never Jack
around on y'all I'll take care of you
I'll provide you with a life that you
can only dream of
this was 12 years ago I mean this is way
before Grant really hit full Grant and
and which she's really uh added to and
made it easier but
um I said look if you if I got to be
less than who I'm meant to be to be with
you
can't give you that
so I said I got books in me this was
before I'd ever written a book I said I
got books in me I'm going to do the
biggest events in the world I'm gonna do
a TV show okay I will I will be known by
millions if not billions of people
and I will leave a legacy
and and and that that has been with me
before I ever met you
and I'm not giving that up because if I
give that up I'll give you up I think
it's priorities just I think it's you
know watching my dad die and and he did
everything right everything he worked
hard saved his money paid his debts off
respected his name he was respected in
the community he did everything right
and when he died my mom had to my mom
had to start hustling and shuffling and
scared and she was he did everything
right and it didn't work so when I saw
that when I saw my dad was my mom was
having to sell my dad's Dream House a
week after he died I'm like something's
wrong with the game he's playing so I've
been challenging the game the whole time
like oh my dad was taught
he was taught the wrong rules and he
played by the rules and it still didn't
get him out it's the middle class
mythology you know it's it's the idea
that I'm gonna have just enough so since
then I've been challenged really looking
at everything that masses of people
believe in family first
you know this people throw that around
all the time I'm blessed everybody says
they're blessed yeah but you know go
Prove It Go prove we're all blessed go
prove it so these are some things that I
just like
like the dream thing I'm like is family
first or what's my dream first well in
my case my dream was before my family
success comes with this okay it does not
the higher you go up the tree the more
people are going to be like look at him
he's gonna fall they want you to fall
they want to take you down okay they
want to hurt you but most importantly
they're trying to get attention for
their own brand or name and they have
nothing to create for themselves
they can't create anything what they do
is they hate okay it's like hate is the
opposite of create you can't create and
hate at the same time they did this to
Jesus they did it to Gandhi they did it
to Oprah they did it to Obama they did
it to Trump okay if you're gonna blow
you're gonna get big if you're gonna
service the world help the world become
a charitable a source if you're gonna
disrupt anything with what they do to
Elon Musk the entire automotive industry
and Biden wouldn't invite him to an
automotive conference where they're
discussing electric cars hey how's that
even possible every great person that's
ever walked on planet Earth male or
female younger old
has been hated on has been click baited
dragged criticized ridiculed dismissed
called a fraud a con blah blah blah so
this is what
haters do okay haters can't create so
they hate
so number one you gotta understand that
this is part of success it comes with
everything else that success comes with
it comes with the money the toys the
winning the victories the happiness the
the celebrations uh what also comes with
success is this the criticizer and the
hater okay it's like building a house
you build a house you're going to end up
with the termites
you have a baby you're gonna end up with
poop
everything comes with a liability okay
so don't don't take it personal that
people hate on you taking as a
compliment I know it's hard
uh number one understand it's coming
number two do not respond directly to
these people
there's no reason to use their name
there's no reason to support them
there's no reason to honor them respond
to them it doesn't matter dude they're
not doing anything they will I know that
10 years from now they will be where
they they won't be anywhere they will
not have done anything they will be off
using or dragging somebody else's name
and I'm gonna create my Empire so go out
create your success
do the things you got to do stay focused
on prospering we send out 40 million
dollars this year in Cardone Capital
distributions 40 million
everybody that drags my name combined
times 10 and times 10 lifetimes will not
generate for themselves that much money
much less give it back to their
investors that's in one year I've done
that I'm sorry that's in seven months
without doing that we've done a billion
1.2 billion dollars in sales over the
internet
you you can put every clickbaiter
together in the same room and give them
a thousand lifetimes they won't produce
that much because you cannot produce and
create when you hate it's not possible
you just cannot be you can't come up
with Solutions you can't make the world
a better place while you're hating on
any one option okay so when I when I
literally put my attention on negativity
on one object how can I create something
good over here it's not possible so
don't be distracted by the distracted
uh the third thing okay you have to
double down on your prosperity and your
success you got to keep expanding what
they hope to do is to contract you
don't contract extrovert keep extroverty
keep creating on the things you're doing
let let those let that that
detraction become an inspiration for
your creation for your continued
creation I remember hearing Elon Musk
say uh something about
um
somebody asked him what do you say about
your
uh the people that say you can't do this
and he looked at him the interviewer and
says we did this
that is really really important go out
and change the world go out and serve as
your customer service the world that you
want to serve just do the things you
want to do use the hate as an
inspiration to actually validate your
creation and to do what you're inspired
to do don't let it stop you don't let it
distract you don't let it introvert you
creating one is part of the game it's
part of the game
it's like anything else okay with every
asset every creation of every asset
comes some liability they're termites
freaking rats
they will never create anything for
themselves and their family that's
valuable much less shared with their
customers
their merchants of chaos like the media
Fox and CNN these people that are
spreading fake news all around this is
the only thing they can produce is on
the backs of successful people so go out
and be successful understand the haters
are coming too use it
use it don't do don't don't recommend
them recognize them talk about them
talk about what you're doing double down
on it 10x on it use it to inspire you to
create more success for yourself and
your family move on and then last thing
is handle your family and friends on it
okay I had a friend once send me
something he saw somebody wrote back in
2020 oh my God I read this I'm like bro
what's wrong with you
what kind of friend
would believe
information from some scumbag you don't
even know
that's not a friend okay and I put his I
put his ethics in artists stop it
don't even ask me about it don't
challenge me about it don't question me
about it how dare are you you're my
friend a friend will support
will support their friends and not
listen to the garbage
they will actually Overlook the defects
of the individual and look at the good
they're doing support them in the good
they're doing trust that they're going
to continue to do that that's what
friends did so don't worry about the
haters worry about the friends they
listen to the books from the haters God
bless be great 10x your family's
important your dreams are important
these are the things that need to be
first on your mind every day
not last it's even the first
last my dreams are first every day then
my wife then my kids
I could take care of my wife and my kids
now would you agree I abandoned this
this is the fuel for who I am I abandon
this dream
and then I end up I can't take care of
them
and I'm gonna tell them what
it's all right that you didn't win no
it's not all right if you don't win you
need to win how many of you need to win
more
okay if you don't control your
environment folks somebody else is going
to control your environment you guys
that run teams and run organizations if
you do not control your environment
someone else will control your
environment you are being controlled in
your environment right now CNBC CNN
MSNBC the parents the kids the Twitter
the Facebook the YouTube the Google the
Snapchats are in your environment your
friends and your relatives your uncles
your aunts the garbage dump called
planet Earth that you live on is mostly
broken people
[Applause]
control your environment it starts with
me
when I was 45 years old I'm going to
control my environment I'm going to take
every penny I have all the energy I have
all the resources I have and I'm going
to improve
if I got to go broke in the process
because I'm already broke look if you're
not fulfilled to your if you're not
reaching your full potential every day
you're broke right now spiritually broke
I was 28 years old three years sober no
drugs in my body for three years I'm
selling cars
and I'm getting good at it too like you
come in and say look I got bad credit
and I'm not buying today I'm like oh
that's two cars
[Music]
I'm a penalizer I'm gonna penalize you
for saying that okay okay
yeah man you got bad credit that's
perfect
at least you got some credit
see I ain't positive I'm there to get
something
so so Captain Ryan says to me he's like
you're the most positive person I know I
said dude I'm not positive at all
I'm 10x
I get results
okay I want to get the deal done I want
to make my kids proud of me
my kids aren't going to remember whether
I was positive or not they're going to
remember whether daddy delivered the
goodies or not
understand when you go to Whole Foods
and they say hey that'd be 427 for three
bags
and you're like I got a good attitude
they'd be like you need to get some 10x
you need to get some 10 x's and money to
go with your freaking attitude
I was 30 years old and I was starting to
speak around the country
partner that I've been working with for
three or four years he said look I said
dude I'm a crossover I'm working on this
one vertical how many how many of you
depended upon a vertical
maybe you're a chiropractor or dentist
or insurance or you're in real estate or
you're you work your Sprint
right and you got this vertical and
you're like dude I love my vertical my
vertical makes me feel good my vertical
pays the bills oh
[Music]
dependent upon the vertical
I'm a little worried that that that that
that you know what I'm saying
I got to keep doing this thing
and I kept telling this guy I said one
day I'm gonna cross over to a mass
audience he says you'll never do it
but he ever does
McGraw-Hill McGraw-Hill you know the
book publisher McGraw-Hill they wouldn't
public
a book called seller be sold
because they said it was a sales book
I said yeah and I'ma sell some books too
National Geographic canceled the
turnaround King how many of you saw that
show
canceled it CNBC copied it picked it up
threw it up on the thing
look this is what's gonna happen to you
folks how many of you have a dream
[Music]
hey hey you gotta go get it
okay dreams don't happen on couches and
they don't happen in bed if you're gonna
realize that dream you got to go out
into the marketplace you gotta meet a
new you
you gotta go through obstacles and
barriers to where it's like that only it
doesn't even bother
me right Elena 26 phone calls because I
wanted to close the deal
she didn't want to go out with me I'm
too short yeah okay I'm too short how
short am I at 51 000 feet
[Music]
how short am I now huh
I sure did my now God damn
I showed him right now we're scoring 666
miles an hour right now at 51 000 feet
huh huh I'll show them an hour
the plane that I bought it was an
expansion decision
the accountant said it doesn't make any
sense man you don't fly enough it's
gonna cost you too much
you don't go on those trips I'm like
dude am I going to expand or contract
it's been 30 years 30 years it's
probably going to be 30 years for you to
doubt uncertainty insecurities
rejection disappointment judgment it's
going to be 30 years of it if anybody
thinks you're going to be successful
without paying that price
you're wrong are you willing to pay the
price I am not here to satisfy you I am
not here so you like oh oh Grant I like
him I don't care if you like me or not
man I want to move a handful of people
in the room to go from 400 Grand a year
to start thinking about how do I make 4
million big boy right over here popping
out what do you would you make last year
would you gross last year
seven
[Music]
seven million dollars a year
you need to make it impossible dude I
cannot I can't my my plane eats 2.7
million dollars a year
this dude needs to think different
he's running out of time man you guys
all in the room man you're running out
of time you're in a space that is so
frothy with opportunity it's
unbelievable you're making sense of less
than you can get this is my mama my
mama's saying I love you boy just the
way you are Mama I made 10 million
dollars on one deal that's great but son
I love you just the way you are I'm like
me just the way I am because I'm doing
deals where I know I could make a
hundred
okay how many of you in a room are
operating below your potential let me
see your hand if you know you're
operating below your potential man
please tell me you operate how many of
you let me see your hand again if you're
operating below your potential
okay your finances should indicate that
your finances are a way to tell the
truth about who you are your space like
if you're an Uber driver and you're
making 2.7 million a year
pat on the back
you're in this space making 2.7 million
here come on man your company's doing
what 2 billion
two billion dollars and you guys aren't
getting it all would you say that you're
not getting it up
a lot of room he's telling me he's in
the first Innings of his game so so I'm
like hey what what do I need to do let's
say 400 is the number then I'm gonna
take this and I'm just going to 10x that
and I'm gonna build a business plan for
four million dollars
and I'm going to quit thinking I'm going
to quit thinking that I that I got to do
a four minute mile
I'm going to quit thinking about the
physical Universe what can I do to
produce four million dollars by the end
is it here is it outside of here is it
here and outside of here how many
customers would I need this is what this
is what my goal for you today is to
leave here and say dude I ain't
satisfied
okay I want to raise the numbers on this
room so the next time there's 75 people
here and everybody adds a zero to your
income oh by the way if you love
yourself at 400 Grand mama
if you love your son just the way he is
at 400 would you love me a little more
if I add a zero no she couldn't love me
anymore it wasn't up to her to love me
it was up to me to love what I'm doing
every day right you guys are showing up
you're working your ass off every day
right or wrong
how many of you making calls every day
you're like I do not want to make this
call and you make it anyway good then
get paid for it
get paid some real money for it man okay
get paid some real money just had a zero
how many calls would I have to make is
this even possible he's doing part of it
he told me I'm not he's not tapped into
all of it
he's hitting 70 percent of that number
if everybody walked out of here and said
hey I'm gonna build a four million
dollar plan I'm gonna tell you I'm gonna
tell you a little a little game I play I
got 14 little companies I run 14 little
companies while I'm doing deals while
I'm speaking to you today right I'm
still running them in my head right now
I got them all open I got browsers open
all over the place
counselor said you got add I said I
ain't got add I don't know how to add I
multiply
I'm done adding I'm done adding a
customer I want to multiply customers I
wanna I don't want to add orders I want
to multiply my orders okay I consider
myself a decent salesperson
but it doesn't matter if you're a great
salesperson if you don't add business to
the sale if you don't become a business
person you can't build out zeros
because you're going to hit you're going
to hit a place where they can't pay you
anymore right or wrong
you got to start thinking about being a
business inside the business
how do I add zeros how do I grow the top
line of my business okay so today I'm
thinking I'm thinking man I'm going to
build a mo I'm gonna build a 10 billion
dollar business I just go into it
backwards I'm going to build a 10
billion dollar business I'm gonna take
the 14 little things that I have
probably get down to three or four how
do I build 10 billion I know the money's
on the planet
say yay if you agree there's 10 billion
dollars on planet Earth dude you could
you could suck 10 billion dollars off
planet Earth today and you wouldn't they
wouldn't even give you like you wouldn't
even make the paper
I just got to think different and I
can't compare it to my upbringing this
is what I did for 25 years
from 25 to 51 years old
spent my most valuable asset time to get
money terrified terrified every second
of every day that's that's really what's
Driven me the whole time was Tara
like when you don't know you're going to
be scared yeah so I'm going out to get
money I won't I won't spend any of it
because I'm terrified if I can't I don't
know how to get more I'm worried I can't
keep getting more
so that I'd get the money and then I'd
rush off and spend my most valuable
asset time again
to bring it to the bank yeah
and then they go multiply it dude
they're telling me to save it and they
don't
and so when I quit listening to every
everybody that's got an opinion about
money online or my neighbors or my
uncles and I started saying what are
they doing
when I quit studying
the influencers and started studying the
banks Goldman JP Morgan KKR there's this
endless list of these guys you start
studying those guys Elon study Elon Elon
doesn't keep any cash
he thinks the whole thing's a joke
which is probably right so so what does
he do he reinvests everything
he's not paying debt off he's
accumulating debt but Apple has debt
Google has debt Facebook has debt and
they have cash reserves that that are
the biggest cash reserves on planet
Earth they could pay cash for everything
why but they don't why do they get debt
when they have exactly why do they do
that because because if I take if I take
man you got a little white boy right
here man okay so if I take uh the Apple
just did this okay I got 90 I want to
make a 90 billion dollar purchase I want
to make a night and they're like yeah we
got the cash for that in fact we have a
Cash Plus another 50 yeah we got plenty
of cash to do this
okay and then one of their people says
okay bro you do that that is not a tax
deductible event
what we should do
is we should go keep this
and go borrow 90 billion really at like
point zero zero five percent uh-huh they
they're gonna pay a half one percent
for this debt maybe they pay one percent
who cares they're like I don't care it's
a tax deduction anyway interesting
so now they have the best of both worlds
they have their cash and they have debt
now back in when I was growing up this
debt would cost 10 12 15 18 it's so
cheap now this debt because we print
money we we money is not scarce like our
parents told us
like when I was growing up I bet you I
heard
I heard at least from my mother from the
age of 10 to 15. if I didn't hear this
500 or a thousand times I never heard it
once
we don't own the electric company turn
those Lights Out Boy
um
still have that going on today
my dad my mom told me my dad would
because he worked so hard dude like he
was so like oh I finally got it I
finally made it now I got to protect it
he got stuck in the second piece keeping
it
you know it's an emotional keep and so
it's it's not a rational thing because
you're hoarding now
you know
still today man it's tough for me to buy
blue jeans if they're not on sale I'm
like this is stupid man like I'm just
gonna wait right you know so so you know
what I'm saying but it's really stupid
that I even worry about it right
and I'm not saying on the come up I
think you should worry about it right
but there needs to be where you can turn
that switch off knowing I couldn't help
my mom when I was 10 12 15 20 years old
um was a really really a very a moment a
long period of suffering for me not the
grief the loss of my father grief that I
couldn't provide solved my mother's
problem it wasn't really about providing
for it was about I wanted to solve this
one problem she had which was scared
about money she's clipping coupons like
so many
families do around the world you know
maybe it's not coupons but the Groupon
or the deal or the plumber or the car
dealer is going to take advantage of you
the roofer is going to come out and rip
you off so you got to get three and four
bits and people are plagued by this all
the time you know do you think that feel
is very practical in the early stages of
your development as as to who you are
today
yeah no it was ridiculous unnecessary
and very costly but would you be who you
were today if it wasn't offer that no I
would be somebody much greater
really oh totally you don't think
completely it was hanging it was
complete it was a mistake financially it
was a mistake right and it was a mistake
spiritually okay there is no reason to
grab something that has been made that
has been manufactured
and then worry about it
don't worry about losing it it wasn't
even mine to begin with and it's not
going to be mine in the end but that in
essence is almost like the symbol the
the real it's the underlying fear is
what drove you that was just a symbol of
fear that was the I guess no no no no no
it was a mistake a mistake wow totally
because I actually heard you talk about
failure and how you you hate failure you
know which is kind of what anybody that
anybody that enjoys failing and losing
yeah is it delusion this is what success
looks like it should be just like this
it should be just like that
okay it shouldn't be up and down and up
and down and up and down and up and down
it shouldn't be good month bad month
good month bad month good money you
shouldn't be that you know what if I get
rid of the Downs if I get rid of the
Downs what do I end up with
all lights man everything that everybody
that my dad did in the Dave Ramsey
program and all the conservative save
your money plan for retirement what do
you call here the super fund yeah plan
for it make sure the house is paid for I
had all that handled
and then that that economic collapse
happened bam three companies
I thought I was good because I had
multiple flows I had real estate paying
me
got a crack
we did we didn't go down we didn't lose
anything but I went back into that fear
and that fear of like oh my God all this
is going to be taken away and so once I
got over the fear I'm like okay what's
really happening here and and what I
came up with was that I had not
accumulated enough unfortunately and a
lot of your audience will hate this this
idea uh because it's going back to that
how much is enough and all that uh
dude I just said if we can flip that
just in this moment for a second it's
not so much about how much it's enough
it's about how much we have that enables
us to do
yeah yeah I'm assuming you're not doing
what you're doing just for the sake of
having yeah yeah like there's a there's
something deep in this you know I don't
like if I just wanted to sit in in a
condo in Miami and on the beach and just
get Sun every day and
I don't need a jet to do that like I can
just stay there right and like we're
doing a lot of traveling right now yeah
and I want to be with my kids so yeah if
you want to be with your kids and have a
nanny and drag them around and you know
do the thing then you got to have some
equipment to go with it and all that
takes money well that's what happened in
2010 I just been thinking too small the
whole time it goes back to that saving
money I shouldn't have been saving money
dude I should have been using my money
to build my brand out so that when that
collapse happened when when a major
contraction happens there's there's one
winner one group of winners who's the
best known
and who can who can deliver at the
marketplace at the lowest price yeah
that's who wins every time who's best
known and who can deliver in the
greatest quantities at the lowest price
the only people that can do that are the
people in the best come on in Atlanta
the people in the best financial shape
yeah you know if you're in great
financial shape I couldn't take
advantage of 2010. yeah right the super
wealthy because you're on the defensive
dude I was on defensive and I didn't
know what I was doing Blackstone
blackstone's sitting there the collapse
happens they're like okay what's going
on here okay okay what can we do now
they're having their drinks different
than America America's drinking to get
drunk to forget this happened
blackstone's in there having drinks
figuring out okay how do we
take advantage of this okay they bought
10 000 homes in Miami in Miami okay
along the beach ten thousand condos put
them together pay cash for them like you
want to be in a position for your family
if you want to have a legacy if you're
thinking about more than just I'm
talking to the audience if you're
thinking about more than just paying the
bills yeah and my dad couldn't do that
when my dad died and he would he would
have wanted to if he was sitting here
right now he'd be like hey man you're
doing the right thing because I left you
guys in a position I shouldn't have even
though he did great he did he he he had
accumulated the American dream but when
he died because he wasn't working
anymore because the income stopped life
insurance kicked in
we had to pay that the house was paid
off
she had some money he had some money in
a in a cash account so my mom got all
that but when she looked at it she's
like uh this could go away yeah and she
went into fear and Terror and and that's
really my message to to people today
that that is still a bit polarizing I
haven't figured out how to deliver it
yet yeah is it look you don't have
enough
[Music]
and the people that get punished are not
just people in poverty it's all the
people in the middle yeah and and I
don't want to be that guy anymore I do
have a plan I always have a plan and
everybody should have a plan and you
need to know exactly what the plan is
and you need to know also that the plan
is going to work okay like I think a lot
of people plan and they cross their
fingers most people have a plan but they
really don't know if it's going to work
I know my plans were like I I know this
plant I know what it was I've been
through three or four major recessions
okay survived all of them and I know
what I have to do each time so I've gone
back and studied what does it take to
move through this I've also studied
hundreds of years of cycles of where
other families became wealthy in these
Cycles these are moments and
opportunities not problems so it's good
it's going to look like a problem to you
there's going to be bad news everywhere
we're in a recession now okay here and
south of here we're in a recession yes
and they're just telling you we're not
but we are and the recession will get
deeper it will be a very long and ugly
nasty recession but there's something
you can do about it so the first thing
is to assess all your situations where
are you with liabilities and assets okay
what's a liability meaning like it's
going to cost you something what's
assets that you could lean into so you
need to assess those in terms of real
you know my phone's an asset right uh
you know this this is this is a partial
asset that's going to become a liability
because it's going to be an empty cup
here in a second I'm gonna need fuel I'm
need water so
assess those things number two I need to
I need to get rid of the liabilities all
of them including people okay family
members brothers sisters mommies if
their liabilities their liabilities you
do not want to drag these people through
this thing because they're going to drag
you down
when you when you have to carry this
stuff with you you need to move fast in
this cycle okay and then you'll go back
and pick them up later okay
okay you can't everybody's gonna if you
guys don't do this plan
and so I'm going to leave them for a
second so that I can go get my assets so
I can expand and create wealth for
myself so which is the third step
looking back on the year how are you
finding time to do all you do Grant like
what does a typical day look like for
Grant Cardone like how do you prioritize
the big rocks daily well the number one
most important thing today was your
interview
so I'm like we got to do that right and
um you know what really happens for me
in any given day I don't think about
having too much to do ever
uh I don't I'd rather have too much to
do by the way than too little to do I do
a lot better and I'm a lot happier when
I got a lot to do
so be be you know I would just suggest
everybody
don't complain about having too much to
do because if you keep complaining about
it you'll have nothing to do
and I think everybody you know has had
the experience of like a day going by in
a snap of a finger because you had so
much to do as opposed to nothing to do
and it feels like the day never ends
there's another saying about you know if
you want something done find the busiest
person and give them the task because
the person that has nothing to do will
not get it done so uh I don't really
worry about too much getting I don't
think about I got too much to do I don't
really think in terms of that but I also
don't do stuff I don't want to do you
know I was driving to the office today I
was late I was doing this interview with
O'Leary and I was a moment late and then
two guys two grown-ups adults are
driving through our Pub a private
parking lot here at the office on
bicycles and I almost hit one of them
and of course you know your response is
when you you hit somebody on a bike on
your property you want to get out and
beat them up first you know and and so
the point of that story is I I made time
for this thing that just showed up on my
radar out of nowhere wasn't on my
schedule and and I made time to be an
idiot for a moment and got emotional so
I don't think it's real that people
don't have time you guys make time for
whatever happens you guys can have
anything you want you got to dream
bigger man you got to do more it's
simple the 2DS dream bigger do more
dream bigger do more dream bigger do
more you don't need to go back to
college
you don't need to go to college
you need to pick one or two people and
let those people Mentor you
you probably need one Mentor that can
help you and the other one is a guide of
what not to do
okay the lighthouse the lighthouse you
know the lighthouse some of you probably
never saw a lighthouse
you know in books you saw a book and
there was a lighthouse in a book
you don't go to the lighthouse
that's a mentor
you don't just need mentors they tell
you what to do you need to pick some
mentors as the Lighthouse of where not
to go
I I have learned more from examples of
what not to do than I have from those
who taught me what to do
see my dad my dad died when he was 52
years old my dad was a great mentor of
mine he taught me how to work hard
I got that work thing down man how many
of you know how to work hard
I can work hard man I can work hard man
I can work hard but my dad could teach
me how to get rich
my dad couldn't teach me how to he
couldn't teach me how to raise a hundred
million dollars online without running
an ad
using social media and do it in 100 days
and by the way I'm on track to do that
right now
okay the next biggest thing I will do in
my life will be crowdfunding for Real
Estate it'll be the biggest thing I've
ever done
and it's all about how big can I think
and how much can I do just assume that
40 million people are going to be put
out of work dude I would act like I'm
gonna 40 million people would be put out
of work at one weekend that's what I
would go into January saying the entire
world is going to shut down uh you're
not going to be able to get anything you
won't be able to get anybody on the
phone you won't be able to use your
internet like just go violent paranoid
yeah and and that way you're going to be
right
because even if none of that happens
you're gonna You're Gonna Act
appropriately that's right which is how
people should act all the time that's
how I act all the time I'm always acting
like like you're broke I'm always broke
yeah but I'm always broke yeah so I like
that a lot you know because no matter
how much success I achieve today no
matter what happens today I'm gonna wake
up Saturday morning
and I'll be like I'm starting over from
zero again right I'm not starting from
where I'm where yesterday and I'm
starting from zero that's right and so I
keep accumulating like that I don't mean
money I mean customer success and that
becomes the unbreakable business that we
talk about I was on a boat a 200 foot
yacht in in south of France and I said
man when you guys are coming through
storms 30 and 40 foot weights like he's
like man we don't worry about the ship
we worry about the crew crew breaks
before the ship does
so that's what's going to happen in
recession your crew is going to break up
loyal people are going to blow off
people are going to quit jobs that
should not quit jobs you're not going to
have to fire people they're just going
to quit like like people go Looney Tunes
okay because there's bad news everywhere
so first thing is hey set a new Target
for 2023 and it's gonna be a big Target
it's going to be giant something that
terrifies you second day we're gonna
handle marketing how much marketing
would you have to do to tell a story
because you're going to be able to buy
ads for a fraction
like we're we're gonna hit we're going
to start pounding Twitter right now
because I know dot uh ad dollars are
moving away from Elon right now so I'll
go in and say you know I'll be I'll be a
huckleberry
okay so we're looking for opportunities
right but that follows that decision
making we want to 10x our business I do
150 million dollars a year I want to do
I'm gonna I'm gonna figure out how to do
a billion five a year in sales I have to
10x mate
so I need a strategy right Marketing
sales then it's gonna be like how big a
sales team do I need to start Gathering
these sales to monetize and this this
activity or we're going to make I need
other communities I need other languages
for me to do a billion dollars I cannot
do it on only English-speaking people
you need you you need like you said you
need people that don't look like it
Mandarin Hispanic kids
snapchatters tick talkers collaboration
you get me an audience that I don't have
like like that's what that's what has to
happen don't try to done trying to
impress anybody
but I do want to inspire people I want
to inspire you so it's been my mission
my mission has been like if I make it
one day I'm going to show you guys
behind the scenes you get to see my wife
my kids how we conduct ourselves when we
go on trips when I'm on business when
I'm at home I want to show people what
it's like to make it okay I'm not
showing you all the cars and stuff and
the planes and to to like say look at me
look at me look at me I'm saying hey man
no
no this is my strategic
literally my my mission a strategic
mission is to show you everyday people
whether you live in in uh in Africa
or America
Venezuela
or you live in Venice Beach California
okay look there's broke people in both
those places
there's hopeful people in both those
places men women kids I don't care your
age your sex your sexual preferences
you're doing drugs not doing drugs you
believe in them or not you're a
republican a Democrat you're a con a
capitalist or a communist
my mission is not political a mission is
to like help people see that
what is possible a lot of you've been
asking me about mine
my workout regimen uh some of you may or
may not know but
two years ago I couldn't do a push-up
I wasn't in terrible shape but man my
body was starting to hurt
you know I'm 63 years old so
there's no way you can't you can hold on
to it without doing the work and when I
was a kid
I was for whatever reason my metabolism
uh genetics whatever I was never uh
I mean I was always I could just pick it
up quick
physically fairly strong but you know
short sharp muscles and they would
respond really quickly
and then
I started believing I could get away
with that
and then you start hitting 40 45 and 50.
this is no way so what I what I did
today you just saw my morning basically
my my routine I changed it up a little
bit I'm in my recovery room right now
this is a magnet uh I'll I'll post some
of the things that it does and
uh some of the benefits of it but
basically what you saw me do is finish
my workout
spent eight minutes on this magnet
it's basically electronic magnet that
separates the cells in the body and gets
everything where it's supposed to be
it's like oxygenating all my cells
then I'll go to the egg over here the
sauna
and by the way I any of you that want
any of these products let me know I
represent all of them
that is a hyper probe it is a 30 minute
30 minute uh sauna it Heats to 194
degrees
Corona cannot live it runs in real
Corona cannot live it 140.
um and that sauna to what a place to
relax man amazing
so I'll spend 30 minutes in that
[Music]
I'll spend 30 minutes in the sauna and
then I'll do 20 minutes into infrared
bed this is a Mack Daddy right here this
bed right here is twenty eight thousand
dollars put that here's I know if you
can even get one
that's a hundred and uh it's the best in
the world 80 000 likes invisible
lighting like it is fantastic for
immunity runs off of a pad over here so
I can pull up everything from
uh inflammation joint pain pain recovery
anti-aging sleep immunity energy soft
tissue recovery so these are three
things I do every day one thing I was
going to say Brian and granted as I know
coming up you talked a little bit about
the recession Grant I know Brian our our
father is an audience are just Avid
about taking action that's one thing
that's great is and that's something you
teach probably Let's Take Action so
Grant you know maybe you guys both talk
a little bit about the upcoming um
challenge you're doing which I love one
of the topics is really how to thrive
during challenges in the recession some
of the things you're going to be
teaching because I think it's so
important everybody that's following you
Brian all of our subs they really need
to get involved in this because it's
some really good stuff of what I've
heard Grant talking about this a few
months ago
like if you guys agree with my statement
about you know sometimes the truth is
not is a painful pill to take
and and as much as the truth might hurt
folks we are going we have 13 trillion
dollars worth of debt in this country
that was taken on in the last two years
oh wow that this is more this is more
debt than than his like we printed
almost 80 of all the US dollars in
circulation yeah happened in the last 36
months now you're like okay well what
what does that mean it means you should
have got a pay raise
if you didn't get a pay raise you did
not get a part of the print
which means your hustle's off uh
inflation uh Warren Buffett says
inflation is it's it's a it's the most
misunderstood Concept in the world and
most people when they hear the word
inflation they get scared but the truth
is your assets should have gone up in
value
the things that you own should have gone
up in value if you have wealth already
you should embrace inflation
if you don't have wealth then you have
to be like okay I got to start getting
some assets because they benefit from
inflation yes and you don't need money
to buy assets but you do need a strategy
and you need a commitment a Target yeah
so like my little company this year last
year we did 145 million dollars in
internet sales in a 12-month period wow
like I don't even have an inventory I
don't have inventories like like I built
this out of recessions to become
Unbreakable
because I've been broke so many times
that I'm like I don't want to keep
getting going backwards you know like I
can't keep going back because I got to
figure out what there's something I
don't know and don't understand
so I had like I had 401ks IRAs I had a
house paid for I got rid of all that in
2008 sold the house
converted the money out of the house and
my IRA accounts to start making
Investments
and and I quit playing by the house
rules Brian that you and I were brought
up on save your money 90-day reserves uh
buy a house pay it off I'm like no I'm
investing all this money in me I'm an
investing in our customers and I'm
invested in my expansion
and so I would just tell everybody right
here Eric based on your question you
guys need to reassess what's an asset
and what's a liability right now right
okay and and because the game is
changing radically in a way you have
time to you have time to re you gotta
really challenge everything you've been
told uh by Wall Street and by your
education and by your friends and family
yes
yes um because the house is not going to
make you money it's never going to make
you money houses are not built to make
money
and saving money in a bank helps the
bank but it doesn't help you in saving
money in IRAs and 401ks helps Wall
Street but it doesn't help you notice
who's getting wealthier the banks in
Wall Street not individuals you want to
do something in life you got to learn a
sales game
I know some of you might be turning this
up right now you're like I don't want to
know anything about sales but before you
turn it off understand this
today I own about 750 million dollars
worth of real estate not all of it looks
like this
uh I've had homes and real estate in
California Arizona
Los Angeles
Austin Texas Alabama
Houston Texas let's see we're all
sponsor I own about 5 000 apartments
right now
and I'm going to share something and I'm
going to give you the link below here so
you can go grab this data
I've written seven books 19 best-selling
audio programs
uh an online platform that's over 30
million people have used and tested out
on companies that pay me hundreds of
millions of dollars to teach their teams
I'm telling you all that to tell you
this there's one thing
in my entire life that I did to
accomplish everything that I have today
including my wife
and my kids and my free time all that
stuff
started
because I learned how to sell
I learned how to sell I learned how to
do something and by the way that I
didn't like to do I didn't like the
sales game didn't like the rejection you
know wasn't comfortable talking to
people not not really that comfortable
doing this video right now but I'm
willing to why
okay so there's two parts of this one
you got to learn the sales game at some
point I don't care what you do you want
to write a book you want to write a a
movie you want to sell a movie you want
to sell music you want to get people to
pick you up you want to be a celebrity
you want to be a DJ you know a plumber
contractor Dennis you got to learn how
to sell period my target my initial
Target in my life has been to work hard
and invest in assets that provide me
with passive income that protect my
Capital provide me with tax write-offs
passive income and mostly to not be in
fear about my money these assets that
we're buying today like this Heights
collection you can't destroy it you
can't get rid of it you can't burn it
down you can't earthquake it you can't
hurricane it it's going to be there
these properties and all the other
properties that I bought look at this we
bought this last year Altis Boca
165 million dollar asset
the uh our bass property in Fort
Lauderdale we're making a big big big
bets on Fort Lauderdale Miami and
Houston that deal was 108 million
dollars doing covid we bought it
distress for 98 million dollars a great
deal this property right here I just
closed on this this is in Boca Raton uh
260. 230 units I wanted this so bad it
was a quick close distress sale off
Market I wrote a check for 69 million
dollars for that property if you guys
are 35 years old 45 years old 55 65 even
75 years old
I'm telling you get your money out of
the market quit gambling
okay the ETFs are a gamble listen the
ETFs are a gamble you think they're safe
and they're not the mutual funds are at
risk you think they're safe but I'm
telling you they're not what's safe is
real assets we're coming into probably
what I Believe In Our Lifetime Brian you
and I this will be the biggest recession
of our lifetime you reckon bigger than
and it's it because it's it's an
Institutional level this time it's not a
bunch of people that took mortgages out
on homes that's not where the problem is
the problem this time is with the
biggest players in the world
and so what I was saying was like Hey so
we started planning this Eric I think I
talked to you about it back in June and
and here we are now we called it
unbreakable because we want to put
people in their households in a position
where they're unbreakable yes and the
thing about unbreakable is this okay you
cannot be unbreakable without money
this money topic sometimes people skirt
around and they don't talk about it but
um I've become famous and Infamous for
telling people you need more money you
know Brian you Britain I don't know 90
books or something right most people
can't do that to get to know an audience
today it's what you had to do 20 years
ago to get an audience today you know we
can do this
yes this is the new book reading of the
21st century for good or for bad yes so
next week we're going to do five
90-minute classes
uh on really getting people to think
about how they can get themselves and
their family in the top one percent of
earners I'm talking to an audience that
wants to get rich just trying to really
like make some make something big yeah
like become like Robert Smith Rich you
know he's the wealthiest black man in
America or Don peoples my friend who's
worth a couple billion dollars in
playing in the real estate game or you
know like I I want to get to the top of
the food chain where I get to start
making rules he who has the goal makes
the rule and so I don't want a little
money I don't want a retirement account
I don't want my house paid for I don't
care about any of that stuff I want to
get rich I want to create tremendous
amounts of wealth for for the people
that that my community for the people it
started off for my handful like me my
wife my kids and then once once I'm like
okay I can help more than that I can
help I can
I don't mean my neighborhood
people in my neighborhood can be helped
right okay they can be helped they need
help another way where I live right down
the street they just don't know they
need help they're rich but they're not
wealthy they're not helping anybody else
dude they're just helping themselves
it's freaking terrible it's a it's a
life of poverty to have your house paid
for it's a mental poverty like oh I got
my house paid for I got my two cars my
kids are going to private schools and
I'm miserable because there's no purpose
uh like I'm helping millions of people
around the world what are you going to
do on a daily basis you got to keep
yourself busy you've got to figure out
some kind of way to keep yourself busy
they're going to share with you my
team's going to share with you a little
schedule I use I'll be talking about
goal setting how to set goals how to
achieve goals how to keep your calendar
full because if your calendar is not
full and you said okay I'ma quit doing
dumb stuff and I'm gonna I'm gonna quit
hanging around these idiots
um well the truth is you got nothing to
do and you're going to sit around and
boredom is going to get you and you're
going to go back and you're going to
start doing the same you were doing with
the same people you Doing It With It
wasn't until I filled up my calendar
with activities
and then got good at those activities
that my life actually changed and the
last thing was I had I needed to start
adding some people that could change my
life so the last three things is you got
to get better at something keep your
activities full when you're winning when
you're doing things you're good at you
will want to do it a lot you will not
burn out on things you're doing well and
the other thing is you've got to get
around the right people why do I insist
that apartments are the greatest
investment of the group why should you
focus here for your initial foray into
real estate investing in short it's
because Apartments passed a number of
tests that are vital to you not having
to worry about whether or not you're
going to make money in a deal okay
you're here to win you're here to make
money I'm all in our apartments for key
reasons first apartments or real assets
when you own apartments and you own real
tangible assets you benefit from a
number of things one you benefit from
appreciation going forward if you picked
a good location cash flow right now now
while you sit and wait and it's more
expensive in the future going forward to
build these apartments than it was to
buy them number two apartments produce
positive cash flow at least they should
if you bought it right if you got the
right debt on it and if you pick the
right property Apartments produce
positive cash flow which is the Holy
Grail of finance a concept that very few
people ever get right almost as
importantly as inflation same thing with
cash flow you're underestimating the
value of positive cash flow when you
pick a property it is cash flow that
gives it value going forward because one
you get to keep it long term and two it
gives you security when you go to sleep
at night now that brings me to number
three this is called the multiplier
effect when rents rise if they do in
your Market apartment values increase if
you're ready to take the next step and
start investing in real estate like a
total Pro you have to start with the big
why why a particular class of asset stay
broke stay broke y'all got to stay broke
man cash is garbage you don't need money
you don't need cash cash is trash your
mommy and daddy didn't know this cash is
garbage it is trash take it out use it
it is worthless until it is put to work
okay listen to me money is worthless
until it is put to work
money is useless until it is used
it's a piece of paper
okay it's got God on it look how they
treat this let's put God on there man
okay we'll put a we'll put Ben Franklin
it wasn't God's idea to have his his
name on a piece of paper everybody agree
with that that's a pitch
come on man put Ben Franklin on this
right he's a president
okay like he ain't he ain't my president
he did
and then we act like a sacred I got to
keep it and protect it and now it's mine
this is what this is what uh Brandon was
doing this morning we're talking about
currency if you look at the word it
comes from current current flows it has
to be in circulation
right it's it's plentiful it's a piece
of paper it's only valuable when I take
it out of my pocket get it out of the
system and put it to work
if I give it to the bank if I call up
Wells Fargo today and say Here's a
hundred dollars what are they gonna do
with it
they're going to convert it it instantly
converted into digits and then they will
send it out nine times
almost 10x I was presenting in a way
that appeared confident and self-assured
and that the person asking the question
actually doesn't know whether I'm
confident and self-assured
you don't know
see it was his perception of me not the
reality so I basically wrote this
article about five tips to handle
insecurity and I want to share them with
you right now the number one thing you
need to know about fear doubt and
insecurity is this most important thing
everyone has them everyone experiences
them it's not like oh my gosh I am so
I'm so vulnerable and so weak and so I'm
so insecure dude everybody has it I
don't care they're three or four or five
people maybe over the entire history of
the world that haven't experienced fear
insecurity and doubt the rest of us are
normal okay I have it all the time I
have fear insecurity and doubt
constantly and I'm going to tell you how
exactly how I'm going to handle those in
the next four steps the first thing I
want you to know is this it's common
everybody experienced it nobody's Beyond
it it doesn't make you bad or weak okay
you don't need medication for it okay
it's normal number two fill your
calendar up a trick I play with myself
not to deal with fear is I feel my
calendar I pack it so tight I'm
literally starving fear because fear
needs time if you jam your calendar no
white space on a calendar you'll starve
fear
fear lives on time okay number three you
want to use the fear look whatever I'm
scared of doing I do it as quickly as
possible okay I actually look for things
each day that I'm scared to do the
things that I don't want to do the most
the call that I don't want to make the
visit I don't want to do the letter I
don't want to send out the email out
those things are the first things on my
list I literally use fear like a
trampoline I want to jump into it jump
into it and hope I get some bounce out
of it fourth thing I want you to do is
start going beyond your comfort zones
you got to get outside your comfort zone
90 of people
want to be comfortable I want to feel
good I want to do what feel good that's
how we end up with you know big Slurpee
drinks with too much sugar in them and
you shoot drugs in your arm you smoke
weed you go out with a girl or a guy
that you you know they're no good for
you but you wanna feel so good
successful people don't want to feel
good they want to feel great successful
people don't want to be comfortable they
want luxury you see the difference do
what you're uncomfortable doing the way
to get luxury is to be uncomfortable not
to seek Comfort get off the Lazy Boy a
lazy boy is for Comfort okay you got to
get into activity do the things you're
uncomfortable with go places where
you're uncomfortable visit people you
don't know yet get out of your comfort
zones the last thing I want you to do
number five is I want you to multiply
times 10. I talk about it in the 10x
rule everything you think you need to do
multiply times 10 okay you dream this
High multiply times 10 and raise it way
up 10x everything okay do it as fast as
you possibly can know that fear and
doubt are normal they're normal 10 extra
activities to where you're like bing
bing bing bing bing bing bing when
everybody else quit you're still bing
bing bing bing bing and you're still
taking action when the next two guys
drop off you're still hitting it okay
the first two guys did 20 things you do
200 last and standing it's a rule in the
marketplace Last Man Standing
think in terms of actions not action
there is no one action that you can do
that is so unbelievable that it would
make a difference you can't tell me one
action hit one home run nobody will pay
attention to you hit a hundred home runs
and the world will pay attention being
an entrepreneur is one of the most
exciting
things that you can do with your life
and the possibilities are endless one
aspect of running a business that I get
asked a lot okay over and over almost
every seminar I go to somebody will walk
up to me and say dude how do you handle
burnout and my replies fast and simple
I don't believe in Burnout that's right
I don't believe in Burnout now I know if
you're experiencing the the exhaustion
that is associated with this idea of
burnout that nobody can prove by the way
that this seems impossible to you that
burnout doesn't exist but I'm telling
you listen to me burnout is not real
it's made up
take a step back for just a second while
I try to sell you on this idea and try
to remember a time when you are on fire
on fire lit up excited about being an
entrepreneur see that's gone right
yeah Grant I'm burnt out that's what I'm
telling you no no no no go back to the
time when you were lit up on fire you
couldn't sleep at night you didn't need
to eat okay all you needed was the idea
of a future you had for this dream this
idea this business whatever see at that
time you were goal driven the
possibilities were enormous they fed you
you were Mission driven
see it's when the mission's missing it's
when the mission goes away that a person
starts to experience being tapped out or
burned out or exhausted at least this is
my experience look when I'm not tapped
fully into my future my goals the
potential the possibilities I don't care
what the job is whether it was me when I
was working at McDonald's the country
club I was working on a rig down in in
in the Gulf of Mexico or whether I was
writing my first book look when your
goals aren't big enough
when you're no longer sold on your
vision your purpose your mission the
symptoms of losing interest what many
call burned out burnout or experienced
anytime you stop reaching for massive
success the next thing you start
settling in
getting comfortable listen settle to
settle
oh I just want to settle down dude why
don't you just put once you just decide
to be to hate your life every day
see that's when you start having
problems when you start selling that's
why comfort and complacency are the
entrepreneur's worst enemy in fact I
would tell you this the comfort and
complacency are everybody's worst enemy
the only time I've ever gotten in
trouble in my life was when I was bored
complacent when I was settling who wants
average who wants average nobody wants
it okay nobody no matter where you're at
in life you don't want average
but we're surrounded by average people
every day average ideas average products
average advertising only those that have
given up on greatness
would settle for average in the United
States today we often hear people say I
just want to be comfortable look folks
that is very dangerous that is very
dangerous to consider the idea of
comfort such Comfort mentality is what
sets entrepreneurs and businesses apart
it's what makes people great is saying I
don't want to be average consider
business
consider the number of businesses or
maybe even people you know that were
once great they were on fire on fire
they were doing great things
and they settle down into complacency
they started resting on their Laurels I
recently was written by a woman
this is maybe 10 days ago she told me
thank you grant today I was fired I said
what I read your book the 10x Rule and
the same week I was fired for being
super competitive
this woman was fired for being too
competitive too on fire and by the way
Grant thank you because I had six job
offers by the end of the week
see folks that's where you want to be
even if you're at risk entrepreneurs are
often criticized for working too hard
have you been criticized lately be
criticized be obsessed over your future
be consumed by the possibilities and
people will criticize you the ambitious
should never apologize
for the only people that criticize them
are the people that have given up the
ambitious should never ever apologize
because the only people that criticize
them are those people that have given up
get excited be excited stay excited and
never settle look this these five days
it's 90 minutes a day you guys carve
about 90 minutes for me every day for
five days completely free cost you
nothing
and I promise you I will put you on
track to become a millionaire yeah man
you know so it's not difficult you got
you I can't do the willingness thing you
guys got to sign up for it I can't do
and I know some of some of your audience
are like ah what's the strings attached
what's it uh the strings that I want to
help that's the string okay if you've
ever asked for help beg for help prayed
for Help Wanted help wanted somebody to
take time to help you this is a gift
yeah and it's my gift to you and those
that receive the gift it gives me a gift
back to me to fulfill my purpose so I
truly want to help people uh this is not
about inspiration or motivation it's not
about you getting all excited beating
your chat is real tactical dude it's a
strategy it's a specific strategy yeah
and I'd like I've never needed
motivation I don't need anybody to
motivate me I don't need to jump up and
down to get excited I don't I don't need
to do a cold plunge to want to conquer
the world or walk on fire dude I need a
strategy just show me the math yeah and
and show me that and then I'll take it
from there and I'm gonna figure it out
just like you did I've created leverage
on my Leverage
on your leverage on your leverage on
your leverage on your leverage you
leverage your leverage like 15
000 times it's unbelievable
yeah I like like in 12 years I didn't
know I could do this right it was
because people started believing Envy
Man one and and then and then when I
started seeing other people do this when
it became real to me
you know that
you know when I saw oh wow what was I
thinking
what was I thinking I'll tell you one of
the biggest culprits
one of the biggest thieves in our
society and one of the biggest mistakes
I made in my career was like simply just
not being around the right people
I was around people that loved me when I
should have been around people that had
done something
you know oh man I love her so much I
love this but they hadn't done anything
like like guys you know you can love you
you know
you need to get around some people that
have done something so you can take care
of the ones you love
because if you're not around people that
have done something you can't really you
can only do to the degree that you're
around winners
I'm sorry your golf game's not going to
get better playing around guys that
don't know how to play golf I've been
investing in real estate for 35 years we
have 4.1 billion dollars worth of Real
Estate
under control right now 25 000
apartments under management and I truly
believe with what's going on the banks
I'm in Phoenix Arizona today Scottsdale
actually and you can see all this
beautiful real estate behind me it's
just you know over the last
50 years real estate has been proven to
be an asset class that when done at the
right time at the right price with the
right debt and the right business plan
real estate has always benefited
from the craziness in the marketplace
you got Banks failing right now or
apparently failing you got money moving
from checking and savings accounts into
the big Banks
and you have office retail apartment
portfolios that are under stress this
could be the opportunity of your
lifetime to start investing in real
assets you Bitcoin people out there that
are so interested in real estate I know
you are because you like the cash flow
you like the appreciation
you like the depreciation none of which
you get from Bitcoin certainly you get
a possible appreciation but no cash flow
no depreciation
and you don't get those big tax
write-ups to come in real estate because
of what is going on in the marketplace
right now at an Institutional level
this is going to be
if you go back to 2008 9-10 when there
was the mortgage debacle what happened
with real estate is real estate some of
that real estate got cut by 30 and 40
and 50 percent if you would have bought
that real estate in 2010 you would be so
wealthy today
you would be like laughing you'd be like
this is crazy I can't believe it now
remember what happened back then nobody
wanted to touch anything
this is when I made the biggest move of
my lifetime I literally went from 200
units to 12
000 units
I exceeded what I thought I could do
okay because I started figuring out how
to actually put deals together what kind
of real estate will always attract debt
good debt and equity
it's not that I ain't you know increase
the amount of money I had what I had I
increased the amount of understanding I
had about real estate itself about what
kind of real estate Goods good debt even
when the the banks are having problems
what kind of real estate can you buy
today everyone talk about cells and you
are a great uh you are great with sales
but I think you are a marketing genius I
have to be honest for me you're one of
the greatest marketer right I'm a better
marketer than I'm a salesperson oh my
goodness and I'm a great salesperson uh
when I and I would rather be a great
better marketer than than a salesperson
why it's funny because because
most people don't like sales okay and
and to become a great sales person like
takes a lot of time and energy okay and
it's almost even a certain kind of
personality which I don't think most
people have
and also even if you become a great
salesperson it's not what you want to
end up being you know great business
people are not great the great business
people you go from a worker then maybe
to a salesperson okay and then a sales
manager and then a CEO of a company or
an executive and then a CEO and then
maybe one day you own the company and
then and then ultimately you don't
multiple companies and run corporations
right that's the evolution well as you
get up here you'll depend on sales but
somebody else is doing them down here
you're dependent on sales to make your
ex that extra hustle so people like look
at this thing I I got to become a great
salesperson but no you want to look over
here you want to start running things it
doesn't have to be your business
but you want to be running sales teams
so in this Evolution you have to become
a great marketer
to the degree you become a great
marketer anybody can become a great
marketer because you can hide behind the
marketing I don't have to be front or
you don't need to be in front right no
well
it's not that I like it it's just that I
do what I have to do to get to to get
attention on the the offer I didn't
start any social media I didn't have one
follower on social David until 2011. is
that right 2000 yeah I've only been
doing social media marketing for 11
years I'm 64 years old I got introduced
to social media when I was 53 years old
it's not native or easy or or normal or
natural for me when I saw the beauty of
social media was number one it was free
number two I could bang it as much as I
wanted okay like as much as I wanted
they won't stop you no matter how much I
drop on it I can say anything I want and
it's not regulated and it's free this is
perfect for me okay you know everybody
told me to do oh there's a specific time
this is a myth there's a specific time
you should Market you know the time of
day uh number two don't Market too much
number three don't monetize Gary
vaynerchuk became famous for going
monetize I'm like I ain't got a daddy
my daddy don't own a wine shop bro I
gotta monetize okay I need money I got
two kids I have to monetize so I broke
all those rules number one I Market
constantly the best time for me is right
now I add links to almost every post
that I do I've I've raised uh one
billion dollars in cash for Cardone
Capital doing this and I've sold a
billion dollars worth of products over
the internet and nobody really even
knows I exist
also the 15 million people that follow
me and follow whoever follows you is not
as important as the Warriors that won't
follow you that will not like you will
not comment you don't even know they're
watching many of them or watching on
Burner phones the most qualified
audience I have is not my followers it
is the voyeur audience intention is
senior to mechanics
and I was like that that was a game
changer for me I'm like man I need to
keep for me that means like
my understanding of that concept is the
intention where I want to get
not not am I a good person or not the
intent what the goal or Target is needs
to be 80 percent
of my energy
so I'm going to get to 5 billion now the
next thing I'm going to do
I'm not going to take a piece of paper
out I might take a piece of paper out
figure out how many deals I need to do
but that's where it becomes problematic
because I'm like okay if my average deal
size is 50 million and I need to get to
50 billion I need a thousand deals right
like I ain't got I can't I
one deal right now much less a thousand
and then you get
a bigger problem and then you're like
there's no way and you give up on your
goal and your intention now and then you
start cutting everything
that's why if you've ever heard me say
never reduce a Target that's what I was
talking about don't reduce the target
increase the activity
to the point to where your goals in my
case my goals should be so big that it
gives me new questions to ask
and the new question would be who do I
need to meet to do a 50 billion dollar
deal right right well the buddies that I
have right now in clubhouse Jonathan
Jerry Glenn David spezak Brian been
stuck they can't help me dude correct
those people cannot help me get to 50
billion they can they can they can be
buddies sure
so that's why if you look at that list
of people I gave you earlier that I'm
studying oh yeah they've all done them
up they've all done 50 billion and more
right
so that's what I need to start real say
what did these cats do who who do they
know what do they now now I'll just tell
you another thing that that is crazy
because I just found this out I was I
was talking to some Wall Street guys and
I'm like do that I hate these Wall
Street people
and I said they're just I'm just not
accepted there I'm not like them and the
guy looked at me says bro it's because
you're talking to the wrong people he
didn't say bro by the way but he says
it's because Grant he's like Grant
you're not talking to the top of the
food chain
the top of the food chain is exactly
like you that's interesting they would
never judge you they would never
criticize you they would only admire you
they would want to pick up the bill with
you they would think they were with a
brother
he says it's everybody they hired below
him that is threatened by you
they said the reason you don't feel
comfortable talking to these people is
because you're talking to one level
below who you should be talking to the
first thing you have to do when you want
to do anything you have to make a
decision a lot of people rush over this
and so oh I got to make a decision yeah
no but you have to make a decision
that you're going you're not going to be
the same in any event like the mo this
moment that you're having right now on
the internet watching us in this
interview you cannot re-produce this
moment you can wish it want it walk on
fire to get it you cannot reproduce it
can't happen no matter how many
decisions you make you cannot reproduce
this one moment
the future however can be created out of
decisions like what decisions am I going
to make
to go from here to there if I don't make
that decision I don't go there
everything everything follows a decision
whether you know it or not billions of
people not Millions not hundreds of
millions billions of people are going to
get smaller as a result of This Global
reset
these are resets these are these are
redistributions of wealth whether you
believe it or not if you go back the
last couple hundred years they've been
doing this over and over again you know
there's this old thing about if you took
all the money on the planet
equally distributed to everyone it would
somehow in a very short period of Time
end up in the same hands why because
those people have specific strategies
one they're making decisions to create
wealth for themselves two massive wealth
there's not little bits of wealth they
want massive amounts of wealth okay two
they they
um they know how to Market themselves
I'm not talking about social media
marketing I'm talking about how do I
just Market myself with you or with you
right now how do I Market My Brand Apple
knows how to do it Coca-Cola General
Electric the the companies that are hot
Netflix knows how to do it you have to
learn how to do that in order to get
money to follow attention so the first
pillar is the decision to get bigger you
and your family have to make this
like you and your wife did yeah my wife
and I okay my kids my kids are on board
I got an 11 year old and 13 year old I'm
like look our decision is to get bigger
and that requires some sacrifices you're
very Scrappy and so it's like do you
ever worry like calling out the black
rocks and these guys I mean you're
basically you know
well it's not a good thing to do if
you're going to stay small
but if you have what they want they'll
they'll forgive you
so what we're doing is we're very
strategic about collecting
the kind of assets that they are forced
to eat okay they they don't they know no
matter how big and powerful you get you
still have a killing seals
right your your your your business plan
becomes your
business plan
you know it becomes the thing that like
if I know your business plan then
I can participate in your business plan
so I can become a necessary evil
to the BlackRock or you know maybe I
could buy you someday maybe or maybe
yeah maybe we do the flippy dippy and I
make my big move bro look you don't
think that these big giants can't fall
they have fallen like all you got to do
is go back hundreds of years man if you
go out on the street and communicate and
there's nobody there to listen
did you did you actually say anything if
you send an email and it hits a junk box
and nobody saw it did did you actually
communicate
if I communicate to you and you don't
actually duplicate the communication did
the communication take place there's a
lot of sales people out there in fact I
would say most salespeople majority
somewhere above three out of four
communicate
and there is no communication there's no
duplication in the communication
I know I know public speakers that get
on stage and speak to
100 people or 300 people or 30 000
people there's really no communication
people in the back of the room never had
their attention never had their full
attention if you've ever seen a zoom
meeting or a corporate meeting and dude
people come in the meeting and they're
all like there's this there's this you
know the delay coming in and then and
people you know can't get anybody's
attention and people are showing up like
there's no communication going on but
you think you did a meeting and then you
wonder why there's no results guess what
it's because there was no communication
even though you spent your time and
energy what does it say
it never happened okay so if if you
communicate and it's not duplicated did
it really happen you're going home and I
said oh I'm so tired I worked so hard
really the reason you feel so tired is
because you did something and it got
nothing that actually was never done
because it wasn't duplicated as opposed
to they where you communicate clearly
and you get results and people buy from
you you go home you're like man it's the
best day of my life
you're renewed why because the
communication went both ways so that
requires you get a stage it requires you
get an audience it requires you to get
attention there's an exact science to
grabbing someone's full attention I'm
not talking about trickery and mimicry
and uh some of these Neuroscience
bullish Sciences I'm talking about
straight up hey
do you hear what I'm saying to you
we are going to go into a massive
recession it's going to affect your
family
did I get your attention did you hear
what I said hey tell me what I just said
and then I get an audience to say yeah
dude you just said my family is going to
get spanked
and it's going to hurt
and then I said yes exactly what I said
your family's going to get beat up
and you can do something about it do you
want to
see I didn't get a clear communication
because I got attention so there's an
exact science to that even some of the
best salespeople I know don't do that
well number one it's real it's possible
no matter what you hear or see or you
know
uh any level of success is real second
thing I would tell young people is don't
focus on sports and entertainment you
know focus on business
you know I I my career will Outlast
every baseball player basketball player
rapper and performer I can go until I'm
99 years old uh I don't need any special
talent
uh the next thing I would tell people is
looking best in yourself don't don't
just invest in yourself to go to college
there's so many better investments in
education like I wouldn't go to college
again personally
I would invest in myself
every day I spend an hour to two hours
studying super successful people on
YouTube have you ever seen how people
talk about different days of the week
you know like oh man I hate Mondays or
Wednesday's hump day or hey thank God
it's Friday or my God I can't wait till
the weekend when you hear people say
things like Mondays this I hate it
Wednesday's hump day oh my God I can't
wait to the weekend you are talking to
people that whether they know it or not
are unproductive people unproductive
first in their minds limiting their
potential and their ability to produce
at higher levels because they are
basically taking four days of the week
and throwing them away I hate Mondays
Wednesday's hump day no Wednesday and
hump day do Wednesday is the fourth day
of the week first of all most people
don't know uh zilch about the days of
the week Sunday's the first day not the
last day Monday's the second day
Tuesday's the third day fourth day is
Wednesday the fifth day is Thursday
Friday's the sixth day and Saturday is
the finish of the week
otherwise you don't know what you're
talking about okay and you can't waste
any of them you only have a handful most
people don't even know how many Sundays
they have but they talk about their
weekends being the greatest time of
their life and the truth is most people
just get in trouble on the weekends okay
what am I telling you here I'm telling
you this got to start paying attention
to your time your thoughts your ideas
and you got to start paying attention to
the people that are around you and what
they think if the people you hang with
hate Mondays you're not going to be very
productive on Mondays would you agree if
Wednesdays is a day named after camels
and you don't live in the desert you're
just freaking confused and if the
weekend is the only thing you got
cherished boom you need to blow your
brains out because your life is going to
be long
ugly and unproductive when I studied and
this is really really important for
everybody you guys start studying
successful people
you know if you want to be a Salesman
the rest of your life to live off
commissions the rest of your life great
study the best sales people out there
but I'm gonna tell you something if you
want to make your life easier
start figuring out how to scale your
sales
and the way to scale your sales is
through marketing I'd rather have 10
people buy from me than one people than
have to sell one person
yeah you know I don't want the hard sale
anymore I want the easy sales and this
isn't about like yeah I don't mind
working hard I got I know how to work
hard but I don't want to work hard every
day
I'd like to work more
at collecting more fruit that wants to
fall off the tree the easy sales and
marketing is the only way to make sales
easy word tracks do not make the sale
easier I mean they'll make it better
you know it'll handle an objection uh
follow-up you know tremendous follow-up
will make we'll we'll almost guarantee
you a sale but in between the follow-up
if you want to speed up your sales cycle
for instance if you're in a sales cycle
that typically is very very long the
only way to make that sales cycle
shorter is through marketing and trust
and marketing is the only thing that
builds trust it's not what you say how
you say or how you dress it is the
frequency at which you show up in
people's ideas or thoughts it's called
omnipresence and we'll teach you how to
do that in January
[Music]
dude that's not a normal State that's
lazy okay that's not normal to be
putting your head down on a table to not
be moving snap and pop do not be adding
wood to your fire look lazy as I wrote
in this recent article that was read by
almost 4 million people with I think as
of today 14 000 likes and just as many
dislikes even people rageful and angry
maybe you're getting like that right now
about my article that lazy is the new
entitlement look just see if this
describes you or anyone you know I only
do enough I make as little as possible I
save as little as possible I invest as
well as possible I learn as little as
possible and hey I work as little as
possible and when my five days are over
with each week I have to I must take
Saturdays and Sundays off I'm entitled
to it these are the policies of the lazy
and they are ruining our country they're
ruining anyone that operates with them
okay normal a normal state is not lazy a
lazy person is actually educated
encouraged acknowledged and it's allowed
lazy is in a loud state in organizations
so if you see anybody in your group in
your organization in your family this
lazy hey knock it out man it don't work
you end up with too little money not
enough love not enough work and not
enough customers lazy is a failed policy
and I'm here to wake you up about it and
one thing that
that has helped me whether it's writing
a book and finishing it
or starting my speaking career when I
did it 30 years old I was going door to
door
the two businesses around America
flew three million miles
go to the city I was living in Houston
at the time
in Bel Air Texas and I'd fly to Salt
Lake City and I'd call on business
owners
I'd set a an event two weeks in advance
commit to the hotel fly to Salt Lake
City knew no one no one knew me I had no
name no books
uh there was no social media and
scared to death
had no clue what I was doing
I didn't know who I was calling on
don't even know how much I believed in
what I was doing like I did believe in
it
but it was like
you know I didn't have any statistics or
facts or success stories
and
regardless of how I felt just like this
morning
regardless of how much doubt there was
or uncertainty
uh
fear
no matter who you're watching or who
you're following
whether it's
political
person uh
rapper movie star
teacher coach parents
I don't care how much in confidence they
put out how much athlete how much
confidence or
a certainty that they push out push out
like like project
they wake up there's days they wake up
and they don't feel it they don't feel
it they don't they don't want to do it
they're uncertain
they're feeling something low-grade
depression whatever you want to call it
look I woke up like that this morning
when
got up family's not here this weekend
uh Elena's got the kids she's teaching
them how to shoot guns this weekend
and I'm here by myself so I'm waking up
this morning like I don't want to work
out I missed yesterday
I'm not feeling it
so what do you do
what do you guys do when you don't feel
it
so this is what I do I just get a little
closer
this is what I do I get a little closer
just like I did when I was 30 years old
starting my speaking career never
thought I'd be one of the top considered
one of the top
two or three speakers in the world when
I was 30 years old I wanted that
but I didn't know how I was going to get
to that
and what I did was when I was having to
fly to these cities Salt Lake City
Winnipeg Saskatoon Toronto Vancouver
Chicago New York like I've never even
been to these places I was literally
flying to cities for the first time in
my entire career didn't know the
language didn't know the the culture
didn't know how they they those little
changes and they
between Toronto and New York New York
and Chicago Chicago and Dallas and
Dallas and Salt Lake Salt Lake and L.A
those are all very very different
markets and different people and
different thinking
terrified
okay I'm doing this today to tell you I
was terrified I was
so scared most the time that it felt
like not fear it felt like depression
like I wanted to take the flight the the
sheets just pull them over my head so
what I did to conquer that to handle
that
I literally would just get a little
closer
I'd give myself a little closer to the
action like this morning I just got
close to the gym I actually went and
walked by the pool I have a pool in the
same spot that we have a gym on the
second floor here and I walk out there
and as I passed the gym because they're
still doing the social distancing
um
there was nobody in here I'm like okay
there's nobody in here to sign I'm gonna
go in there and work out okay so number
one just try getting a little closer to
the action hope that helps you just get
a little closer you don't have to commit
to doing it completely just get closer
to it I came down here dressed uh put
that I put that on before I left so I
was ready so I got a little closer
second thing dude if it calls you do it
anyway
you know I coined this phrase years ago
do it anyway
a buddy of mine about the same time I
was starting my business I was having a
lot of problems in my life I was
probably
it was before I started my business I
was still in Houston Texas I was going
through tremendous tremendous amounts of
uncertainty doubt about myself I was in
a transition a career transition just
lost a job
starting my deal and
I went one year one year without working
I've never ever shared this before one
year and I did not I mean
I had a little bit of money saved and I
was going through it I didn't I didn't
literally I looked like I was working
every day but in truth I was not working
my twin brother actually knew that and
finally confronted me and that's what
got me off my ass but
in the morning and no matter what you're
feeling
no matter how much you hurt
if your eyes are bleeding
do it anyway and that has stuck with me
now for 30 27 28 years do it anyway no
matter how it feels do it anyway so
number one get a little closer number
two do it anyway
and then number three okay regardless of
the outcome of what you did when you
showed up to present make that phone
call uh go to the workout once you get
in there come on man put all you put out
put give it the best shots you got once
you're in there once you're in there
once you get going just start moving in
that direction like I just went and
jumped on that thing for three minutes
the next thing you know I'm like hey I'm
glad I'm in here so third thing once you
get in there go all the way okay I'm
gonna do that right now God bless you
hope you're doing well hope you're
finding greatness in your life struggle
through it push through it remember just
get a little closer to do it anyway
three once you get in there put you back
into it put your ass into it put your
head into it just get into it because
it's probably going to be easier once
you show up
uh to do that than if you had it if you
get to number three and you're having
struggles remember when you leave at
least you showed up at least you gave it
something and then do that again
tomorrow who do you need to be connected
with long term because you're going to
have to change your friends you're going
to have to I don't I don't mean get rid
of the friends and family that you have
but you're gonna have to add some new
friends a new family new peeps a new
network you know they say your network
is your network you guys
well that's true for you to keep scaling
10xing 60.
600 6 million it's all possible I
promise you if I can do it you can do it
I went from being a God it was a one-man
show one-man show to running companies I
got a 200 employees here 350 in our real
estate uh Partners all around the world
and it's only because of these four
things I'm going to share with you in
the 10x income system which is
first middle second and second is hey
what is my strategy to get to the next
level three three is am I in the right
vehicle picking the right Vehicles okay
real estate's a great vehicle uh
coaching's a great Vehicle Health Care
is a great vehicle
um education is a great vehicle I'm in
all these but by the way right now using
online today the metaverse is going to
open up all kind of opportunities for so
many people I'll be right there webinars
online uh phenomenal opportunity for
everybody out there if you're in the
situation right now you don't like it
you don't like where you're at you don't
like what you're doing you're limited
you're stopped you're stuck okay grab
this take advantage of it okay I'm
telling you it's a game changer it's
going to give you what you need what you
need
what you need so that you can have what
you deserve everybody deserves a great
life everybody deserves the ability the
ability these guys will go crazy if I
come in here okay you deserve the
ability to
um morning
uh to uh
make more money period because the truth
is if you don't make more money you'll
never have money to invest and you'll
never get to the second Hustle the third
one the fourth one you'll never get to
the multiple flows and I want to show
you here how to get multiple flows of
income literally I have three income
flows today that I do nothing
and they provide me with income every
single month how many of you have a key
or retirement account of some sort yeah
good it's garbage it was a bullish thing
to rob you
how many of you own a home right now let
me see a hand
it was it was and you
put your money in there you wanted money
and you bought a house you wanted money
and then you put it in a excuse me in a
retirement account
you wanted money and then you gave it to
Wall Street you can't even get your
money what you do man what were you
thinking
all right my mama told me a house is a
good deal do you know any rich people
that say my house made me Rich
foreign
[Music]
like if I had my whole career to do over
again I would teach people about money
because basically what I've done for for
30 years you know while I was building
out these other businesses I was buying
real estate every time I'd get a surplus
of money I take the surplus of money I'd
push it off to the side okay let me just
show you the Simplicity of it okay first
of all I got to make more money
everybody agree everybody agree with
that dude you got to make more money
because if you don't make more money you
ain't got any money this is what Susie
Arman says don't spend your money don't
spend your money don't spend your money
don't spend your money you can't afford
it you can't afford it all you had to do
was go make some more money
okay
right but what did she tell you don't
spend it you can't afford it the truth
is you need to make more money number
one you got to make more money or and
really in the case don't make it you
need to collect it
or get it
who's got my money
number two what do I need to do now
I need to keep the money
it's not big words
and by the way just because it's not big
words doesn't mean it's not valuable
what am I keeping the money for I didn't
say save it by the way I said keep it I
don't need you to save money there is no
money made by Saving today how many of
you know about compound interest
you're like compound interest is the
Holy Grail no no not today it didn't
there is no compound if you're making
point zero four percent at the bank
today's national uh Friday's average
savings rate in America was 0.12
percent
that ain't 12 percent that's point one
two percent that's not 1.2 percent
that's 12 tenths of one percent it take
you eighty years
to make ten percent of your money
[Music]
okay my mom was earning 10 or 12 20
years ago she was earning 10 to 12
percent in the bank so every seven years
that money doubled you know the rule of
seven
the seven it was a calculator right if
you earn 10 on your money every seven
years it would roll over and double
okay do this I think this is like I
don't know 144 years to double money
[Music]
three trillion dollars sitting in Banks
how many of you have a partner you have
a partner in business
good how many of you do not have a
partner in business let me see your hand
okay yeah you do it's the bank
you took your money and you trusted a
bank with it
what does the bank do
they think the paper's so useless they
get rid of it
[Music]
you can't get your money back how many
of you saw the video I did where I tried
to get a million dollars in cash for my
bank
somebody said Grant you can't get your
money I said what do you mean man got me
all freaked out stopped my whole day
what you mean I can't get my money man I
saw it on my account man and then maybe
I hung up with the phone with him I'm
like I wonder if you get my money I
don't know
the things that I invest in today I
promise you will be around longer than
Facebook
listen to what I'm telling you right now
okay in your lifetime there might not be
a Facebook this phone right here how
many believe this phone this phone will
cease to exist in the next 20 years
ain't no way this phone's going to be
around 20 years from now
okay the things I invest in
will outlive this phone we'll outlive
Apple computer that's the only thing I
go out every day this is how I think
about money I'm running every day for
money I'm busting my ass man I'm
busting my ass every day I'm busting my
ass I I you know I'm busting my trying
to fill up the refrigerator take care of
the kids get good education for them
fuel the plane up put fuel in the plane
fly the plane take care of the plane
watch the plane invest in my business
right this is what I'm doing all day
long you know and then and then what I'm
trying to do really is I'm trying to I'm
trying to
put this money to use at some point okay
operate with what's called what I call
is a 40 point I'm looking for 40 percent
to save on my income whatever it takes
how much money do I need to make so that
I have 40 percent
that I can take over here and shove a
big giant piece of cake into a deal who
in the room likes sales you're like I
just love
you love it okay stay away from this man
keep your kids away from it stay away
from him okay
it's a whack job right here okay anybody
that likes sales he only likes it
because he's good at it
because there was a time when he didn't
like it nobody naturally likes
approaching a person
presenting a product
asking them to buy it like everybody
gets uncomfortable right
so so one thing one trick that I thought
that that was the whole trick in
business like I got to go out and sell
something that's not the trick you need
to build a business and everybody in
here's the business she is a business
her job is to get attention for her
brand discover her brand clarify her
brand yeah that's my brand don't be
stealing on my brand but she could she
could she could ride she could ride
she's collaborating with me when she
does that
collaborating with a brand we we invited
you here so we could collaborate with
you
how many of you went to our conference
here in Miami
okay oh a few of you okay it's 35 000
people there 35
000. I have more people in Marlin
stadium
than the Marlins can put in their
Stadium
the Marlins and the Dolphins
that just shows you how important
success is
right some of you were going to go to
the game this Sunday you're like I ain't
going hey I wouldn't go here much less
New York right so because nobody wants
to be around losers
like bottom line so you got to get
yourselves it's easy to talk about the
Dolphins right okay but but you got to
get yourself in a position where you win
it folks
you know I remember there was a time in
my life where I I didn't want to be
around me
I knew I had this much potential and I
was delivering like right here I didn't
like me I hated me
same thing when I started having a
business my business had three or four
employees
I didn't like that about me because I
knew I should have more employees earn
some power earned the right to have some
power some responsibility keep the power
okay and save and multiply you want you
want to multiply you don't want to hoard
it it's not about keeping it to keep it
for yourself it's about how do I now
multiply this is what your mom and dad
said this is what my mom and dad didn't
know they knew how to keep it
they did not know how to multiply stuff
okay that's why with most of your if I'm
right about you in this audience just
from looking at you judging you a little
bit is you were probably brought up the
way I was eat all your food
I remember taught that three times a day
eat it all eat it all eat it all if you
didn't eat it all put it in the
refrigerator you're like look I didn't
want it hot I'm not going to want it
tomorrow I don't want this this done I
don't know shave it save it somebody
somewhere starving somebody somewhere
and I'm like dude like like you guys go
back to your refrigerator tonight see if
you're not affected by this open your
refrigerator and look in and see how
much
that you
see how much stuff
from Jared see how much stuff that
you're saving that you don't want
that you don't want to eat the only
reason you're saving stuff you don't
want is because you're worried about
earning more period Then I want you to
walk to your closet just a little
exercise go to your closet open your
closet and I want you to look at shoes
pants slacks jackets that you haven't
worn in years
probably don't even fit you but you
refuse to throw them away
I gotta save it I gotta save it I got to
save it because you're worried about
earning money enough money to pay for
more stuff because you know in your
heart of hearts you know that mechanism
for you is broken
you have to fix this you have a
responsibility to fix it so you can do
nothing tonight
okay it will not get better you can go
do it on your own
most of you look like you've had enough
time how old are you sir
he's had enough time at 41. dude if you
ain't fixed it in 41 uh whatever data
you have
got you in that chair and that that's
that's what I know about myself I have
to change for me to change I have to
change and for the for the most part
that doesn't mean I need to do more it
means I need new information I am an
extremely hard individual okay I know
what it takes to be in the position I'm
in it is not easy okay I have paid
attention for 30 years to everything
when it comes in and when it goes out
and where it goes and whether or not
this energy that came in or the energy I
put out hey does it actually pay me so
that I can produce something in the
future okay anybody anybody can have
this much success in life
to string it together for 32 years never
have a bankruptcy never not pay a debt
never ever ever okay walk away from
something I didn't know it is very very
difficult
going out knocking on the door making
some money getting a sale great winning
of course in a case in court great okay
getting a degree to college good you can
do that okay anybody can do all that
stuff to string together 30 years
and be able to survive recessions okay I
am an extremely intelligent person when
it comes to money okay we're the most
resilient
people on the planet I mean except for
maybe persons
I mean really Persians are unbelievable
people okay again the Romans the Romans
were pretty successful okay but but you
notice if you look at those
civilizations man Persian look there was
a time when they had everything they had
it all and they lost it because they
started making mistakes they started
thinking oh well we'll go on forever we
don't have to be diligent we don't have
to pay attention we don't have to do the
right things okay you were on a ship
[Music]
you're on the same ship I'm on okay I
own the ship but guess what it won't
matter it won't matter when the ship the
ship goes through rough rough orders hey
your stomach's gonna feel the same as
mine
I'm not the only one that is scared in
these Waters I just know I ain't getting
off the ship
for you you actually could say and I'm
gonna get off so I can't get off you
understand this is my show
okay my ship's gonna finish this trip I
did 35 years of this I guarantee you I
will die on that ship okay and I will
find other places to go adventure and
other places to have victories and other
civilizations to meet okay this is my
trip and if you want to be on it with me
for the whole ride you can be you can
get off anytime you want to probably
half of you will at some point get off
say I'm done here I got that man I will
pull into Port one day we'll drop the
what's that thing we'll drop the anchor
yeah
well hopefully you don't get off on the
gang wall
the gang walk means we push you off
hopefully you wait till we get to Port
and then you get off and then you walk
off into the village and you get uh some
some woman in the village pregnant
you settle down there and
you're a new civilization
it's what we used to do man it used to
be cool
okay can you imagine back in that time
hey new place let's go visit the people
hey are we going to be here in the
future well one thousand percent are we
going to do another 10x good conference
guaranteed
okay I mean if I'm not going to do
another one of those I'm not doing any
like I'm done I need to go home get on a
ship and travel around and and not come
back to work anymore are we going to do
are you going to buy more real estate oh
for 100 sure
so you're not going to stop this brand
and and the the the desire people have
and my mission is to help people
so and I cannot do this by myself every
one of you is needed okay but I need you
I need you right now to lean into this
thing
your job depends on what you do every
day your job depends on
okay not not your job with me your job
period on this planet
depends on how much you take your
shoulder and put it against a will and
push and get a product a product
okay for us this products are people
know about Grant Cardone people know
about our webinars people know about our
opportunities people know about our
books I need you to do more than your
job I'm already paying you to do your
job
okay
you're not going to get a bonus if you
don't do more than your job I'm just
telling you
I will not get a bonus if I don't do
more than my job Kevin Hart will not get
a bonus if he don't finish that movie
if the tickets don't sell Kevin Hart
will not get the bonus you have the MLB
baseball players for the Marlins they do
not get paid this year if there is no
season you understand that
they don't like oh I'll get my check
anyway you didn't play bro
okay if I get hurt in the NFL and I
don't play I don't get paid that's the
real world
so when I get to when I hear the numbers
in the morning sometimes you guys don't
see me there because when I hear we got
a hundred licensees I'm like God damn we
should have 10 000. and everybody in
this room should have sold one and got a
commission on it
but again if you don't like if you're in
shipping Sherry told me somebody in
shipping them like why is that person in
shipping when's that person how can that
person live on 16 an hour
or twenty dollars an hour we took them
down from 20. how can you live on twenty
dollars an hour
in Miami
[Music]
I'm not going to pay any more for the
position
how can you make sense of it I don't I
don't understand that like
there's all this other stuff we have to
sell man everybody every time I meet
somebody coming to my boot camp coming
to my webinar you coming you got a book
you got this program you got a wristband
okay how about a t-shirt
like like every time I talk to somebody
I'm like once you grab one of my things
because I know that drives a little bit
of Exchange
once he gives me money he has a
relationship with me
the moment he gives me money we actually
complete the relationship it is only
them okay you guys that are on Natalie's
team you you can call and talk to these
people and help them as much as you want
you're not actually having a
relationship when you do this help
when they exchange back with you you
complete the health cycle okay they have
to give you something for the help
otherwise it's a handout
and nobody wants to handle it
except people that have given up
and lost self-respect of themselves
nobody wants a handout they want a
little hey come on you know but nobody
they'll resent me if I keep giving them
a so remember when they say hey
I want something great make sure they
give you something back
okay so so that we can complete that
relationship or start one and we can
start actually doing business with one
another what are you going to do when
are you going to start doing it this
isn't about a convention a conference
it's not about enthusiasm do you need to
smile yeah you need to smile you need to
smile like you crazy
you need a smile when you're not winning
but you need to do something folks and
you need to do it 10 times and then a
hundred times and then a thousand times
and if you do it enough times you're
gonna win
you're gonna get to sit wherever you
want in life on whatever plane seat
whatever Hotel you want to be at stay as
long as you want come and go as you want
if you don't want to go you're like dude
just cancel the plans but but we're
inside of 24 hours they're gonna keep
our money keep it I can get some more
it wasn't even mine
okay the money I got in my pocket right
now nope see Elena's got it all
the money Elena has in her purse
with somebody else's money
see but we're taught that there's a
shortage in their scarcity and you don't
have any all you have to do is be
willing to call somebody
talk to somebody
make contact
if it's not getting you the result tweak
the contact and increase the calls
and by the way if you don't want to do
two things don't tweak
and just increase the calls
if I call enough people I can say
anything I want to say
okay if you're taking notes write this
down no one thing will ever blow a
prospect
no one thing will ever blow a prospect
there's nothing you can say that will
mess a deal up not one thing most people
don't know how to create money okay the
most important thing about money and
getting what you want is not to have the
money it's to create the things you want
live where you want have the expansion
you want the views you want go where you
want number one you have to know how to
make it most people don't know how to
make money number two fewer people know
how to keep it that's discipline you got
to have discipline and you're not going
to have discipline if you don't have
goals why would I keep money
if my goals are either perverted
short-sighted or maybe too small okay so
you got to have monster goals and and
that's going to create the discipline
necessary to keep what you went out and
earned and number three number three
then you got to figure out how to
multiply it okay now you don't need to
figure out how to multiply it when I was
25 years old and I'm broke I didn't need
to work on multiplying it I didn't even
need to work on keeping it because I
didn't have any
in the beginning in the very beginning
from the age of 25 to 35 all I did was
work on particularly in the first three
or four years all I worked on all I
worked on was how do I learn how to sell
man that thing is bright how do I learn
how to sell how do I learn how to Market
how do I learn how to promote how do I
learn how to handle people's objections
I'm talking about basic basic stuff if
you count all the live stuff that we do
on streams I mean it's every day but I
started my career when I started my
career I was doing
I was probably doing eight a day eight a
day every day training for 250 days of
the year oh my goodness that were
anywhere from 15 minutes if I could get
a company to listen to me these were
free presentations I was trying to it
was you know we were talking about the
importance of communication I was trying
to get known yeah in America yeah and
the way I did that was I'd go knock on
doors and say hey I have an idea for
your business I'd like to tell you about
it I'd like to share it with your
employees it's free it doesn't cost you
anything
and just listen to me for 20 minutes so
those were like I did tens of thousands
of those in order to get known and they
were converting into business uh well I
didn't know what I was doing they were
the goal was to convert yeah but it took
me three years to ever make any money
this is before I've written a book I
didn't have a name nobody knew Grant
Cardone and um
you know I hadn't quite figured out me
yet
um but every once in a while somebody
would say yeah yeah we like your ideas
and we want to do this and then they
would go to this event that I would plan
two weeks later so I had two weeks
planned for an event like you know how
hard events are to do incredibly yeah so
we figured out how to put you know two
or three hundred people of the right
people in a room for an event we took 14
days to Market it it was me doing all
the marketing 14 minutes 14 days I would
Market I would go but I'm calling on
businesses door-to-door yeah and uh very
much a marketing and sales job
very very the most difficult thing I've
ever done in my life I was 30 years old
so you know I was doing 250 gigs a year
than a than a promotional company picked
me up and we started doing eight of
those larger events right a month so I
was doing a hundred speaking gigs a
month a year a year a year a month I'm
not feeling when you're up now we've
been giving giving yeah you no no I do I
did one hour in Bucharest I got on my
plane I was just like Wham yeah yeah and
it was only one hour that that's when I
was doing eight hours yeah going to the
next city doing eight hours not Not only
was it extremely taxing on me it wasn't
it wasn't good for me and I don't I
don't know that it was good for the
audience it definitely wasn't good for
me as a businessman because I was
spending too much time speaking and not
enough time in my business today we
flipped the model where I'm spending
more time in my business and and less
time on stages there's a lot of people
multi-level marketing that say that they
have passive income I'm like that's not
passive income
that's a residual income not passive
what's the difference between passive
and residual income passive income is
I'm making investment and somebody sends
me a check
a residual income and it could be
residual it could be repeating recurring
right right but if I if I go collect the
rent paint the place
put in the tenant that's not passive
that's active income
I had to rent it I had to collect it
your trading time for money you had to
Market it you had to do it what you get
for me is passive you you know you you
don't decide what color of the paint on
the building is no you don't you haven't
even been to the building no I can't
believe it's the 15th again right that's
passive income right dividend income is
passive income you you invest in Apple
computer and they send you a check
but if you have to work for it it's not
passive no so the CEO of Coca-Cola made
50 million bucks last year
a lot of money right okay that's earned
income government's going to take half
of it Warren Buffett invests in
Coca-Cola
he was paid 508 million come on last
year
that's passive income as a dividend yes
and he doesn't have to pay taxes and you
know how many people on the internet
want to be the boss
a lot dude the boss don't make any money
the investor does
um
don't be the boss don't be the CEO
this is there's so much confusion in the
marketplace be the investor yeah just
invest
and what has warranty Warren is how I
got in real estate
I started buying real estate because I
studied studied the old man the old man
when when when I would read well the old
man's only invested in stocks right I'm
like I'm not going to do stocks because
I don't like them but what I wanted to
learn from Warren Buffett what what was
he doing what was the consistent
patterns of what he invested in
all companies that were had been around
a long time
he did not buy the cheapest company he
never looked for what my uncle looked
for
he didn't buy a low and sell High what
was he doing he bought fair value in a
fair price he bought the best quality at
a fair price he didn't look for the
lowest price
he wasn't looking for the the day a
stock went down to one dollar he never
did he's never done that he invests in
companies that all cash flow
leaders in their space
Coca-Cola sea can candies
um Apple computer he didn't buy Apple
computer for years until he understood
that Apple computer was a cash flow
company because of iTunes wow that it
wasn't a computer company it was a dash
flow generating machine when I read that
I'm like dang dude everything he buys is
really real estate you see so I'm like
okay I can't get the I cannot buy a big
enough position I'm not rich enough to
get a big position of Coca-Cola I don't
get on the inside I'm a little guy right
so I'm never going to get access to Wall
Street Goldman Sachs ain't gonna call me
and say hey we got this deal going man
let's go to the next Coca-Cola right I'm
never going to get that call
so what can I buy this like Warren OH
real estate man I could buy the 26 units
in San Diego because I know the
neighborhood I grew up there and and I
spent some time there so I know that so
I can buy that I can go to the bank I
can get a good loan on that and at cash
flows
and and that's how I started buying real
estate because Warren he bought for the
long term he bought great locations for
great properties fair price he he's
never managed anything
he's not the CEO of the company he's not
a manager he's not a CEO he never gets
rid of the the employees that are there
and I was like man what are you doing
dude
he's not the salesman but he is a
promoter so when I started watching with
his moves he's on TV all the time
and he takes big positions giant
positions
not little ones that all that changed
everything uh for me I quit
buying this and a little bit here and a
little bit there it's called
diversification I quit doing that when I
watch Warren Warren is not Diversified I
think four Investments gave him 70
percent of all his returns last year wow
yeah
and if he wasn't so rich he'd probably
only own three or four stocks but he's
got a he he's so there's so much money
now elon's another guy never Diversified
PayPal was his only investment when he
sold PayPal he only has three
Investments today and no homes
and no cash really no cash
oh he does in a real estate or he
doesn't know his home he doesn't own his
homes
he's all in man yeah but that's not the
advice our parents gave us or our school
teachers right where is housing going to
be in the next eight to ten years do you
think it's gonna be what he's going to
have people in them right and it's going
to be more expensive and I think people
are going to be more renters and then
they're going to be owners hey to all of
you out there that are having a hard
time right now
if you bet you're getting beat up
maybe you're broke you don't have any
money girlfriend or boyfriend left you
had a loss in your family
[Music]
lost your job
I got a little message for you okay
here's the deal
number one it can get worse
okay it can get a lot worse than it is
I know I've not always lived up here
where the view is good
telling you
keep feeling sorry for yourself it's
going to get worse and worse and worse
now
with the prevalence of experts
on the internet including Instagram
YouTube Facebook Snapchat Twitter
and the
plethora of people that literally
can make quotes and memes knock off
Abe Lincoln's quotes and take credit for
them
there's no shortage of people out there
saying it's going to be easy for you to
be successful
look it's not going to be easy okay the
advice you're getting out there is so
wide open there's so many people telling
so many people garbage
like it's going to be easy you're going
to be able to travel all over the world
all you have to do is become an instant
celebrity or a star on
any channel or
all you have to do is start posting
pictures of you and cars or you on trips
or you working out or look it's just
it's endless and it's driving me nuts
that some of you out there that are
getting your brains
like handed to you
and you're sitting there you're like woe
is me what what is wrong why can't I
make it all these people are making
number one you don't even know if
they're making it
you don't really know if they're making
it you don't know what their life's like
or if they're happy or or if they're
really successful if the money's real if
the cars are really if the trips are
real you don't know any of that so so
number one don't
feel sorry for yourself nothing's going
to change because you feel sorry for
yourself I lost five my first five jobs
I was broke at 25 the more educated I
got the more broke I seemed to be my mom
and my twin brother said look leave us
alone get your freaking stuff together
and then
uh maybe you know earn your way back
into our Graces I was the black sheep of
my family I didn't even like myself and
me blaming others me feeling sorry for
myself didn't change things and most
importantly and maybe a benefit to me
was there was nobody on the internet at
that time saying
uh I became an internet star and that's
how I made my millions of dollars
I just wasn't available only thing
available back then was you got to work
okay you got to work you got to go out
into the marketplace you got to pick up
a phone you got to start where you are
you have to take that sucky crummy job
that you have and do whatever it takes
to start putting money together you
don't need to go back to college you
don't need to go get another degree
some of you got so many degrees you
could be a freaking thermometer
like you got to change the game okay you
got to get tools and skills simple tools
and skills so you can start monetizing
whatever your skill is
so number one you got to knock off the
excuse making it can get a lot worse I
promise you can get terrible I thought
it was bad at 23 it got worse
okay it got worse so I want to help you
but you got to drop the quick get rich
quick thing it's gonna be easy I'm gonna
become a star I'm just gonna start
knocking off other people's quotes I'm
gonna put up pictures of uh uh of cars
and trips and and think that that makes
me successful it's not okay you can't
steal somebody's profile and think
that's going to make you successful
got to work you have to monetize okay if
your daddy didn't leave you with a
business you have to go out and do
something today today that adds value to
the marketplace and get you money
okay money
nobody's telling you go get money
sell a product okay now you could sell a
product out of your closet but you're
not gonna be able to duplicate that
again tomorrow so I strongly suggest
that you get products that you can sell
a second time a third time a fourth time
a fifth time you got people out there
just dropping f-bombs telling you don't
do anything you don't want to do don't
do the stuff you're no good at
well you're not good at anything right
now so you've got to do something right
now everybody has to start somewhere it
starts with you taking responsibility
for you
and saying hey I got to go out and get
one little skill at a time I got a man
up woman up I got a bone up and I gotta
go into the marketplace and add value
sell a product sell a service do
something for the money work for
somebody else become the most valuable
person in your space
that's what it takes folks there's no
shortcuts okay today I'm living up here
I live on the 33rd floor
of a beautiful condo
200 panes of glass in this place you got
glass all over the place okay I don't
even know what we spend to clean the
windows it's ridiculous
when I grew up
I had one little window one little
window it looked at a brick wall
okay and that's when I was a kid as I
grew up and got more of an education my
window got smaller and smaller and
smaller and I was acting like I was a
I was acting like I was uh
together
okay so look got to get a good job
how do you get a good job you get the
job you're at you get good at it I don't
care what job it is
I lost five jobs all five of them they
should they probably shouldn't have
hired me and they did they gave me a
shot and I lost them I deserved to lose
all five of them they shouldn't have
kept me there as long as I was
if you got drug problems alcohol
problems you're going to have to get rid
of them okay you're going to have to
confront the Beast if you got a bunch of
freaking loser friends around you got to
get rid of them
you want the great life you want the
real deal life it's not about posting it
online it's about living it it's about
doing it it's about paying the price all
the successful ones paid the price when
I was a kid when I was growing up
the guy that the guy that knew how to
take care of his environment was my dad
I was eight years old and then this dude
this dude controlled everything in this
environment
the early for work he came home late
took care of his family and you knew he
never gave anybody a lecture about what
to do
he he just he was a good example
and he had the money and he made the
money
we were middle Club middle class family
so we were like
Little Red Brick House White brick
actually white Brick House about 1400
square feet seven people lived in it
and my dad I could tell my dad was
trying to get somewhere he was trying to
move us up
he was trying and he wasn't trying to
brag
he was trying to take care of
and so I was watching that right and I
watched where this guy he he's the one
that made the decision where we went how
long we stayed and I started associating
that the money maker makes the rules
this is what Elena was talking about you
know there's around the money I make the
rules around the money around other
things Elena makes the rules so you got
to know what you're good at what your
job is and what your role is my dad and
my mom knew their roles
[Music]
Suddenly at 52 years old my mom was left
to do something she didn't she didn't
have she was not skilled up to do
and and I was 10 and I wasn't I didn't
know how to help my mom
and my dad left a little bit of
insurance money from the from the life
insurance or the death Insurance better
better it's really Called Death
Insurance just can't sell it if they
call it that and
my mom didn't know how long that money
would last so immediately after my dad
died when my mom should have been in
grief she would went immediately into
massive fear and I could see it I could
sense it as a 10 year old my mom was in
fear every day
clipping coupons saving money
you know turn the lights off
eat all your food it was constant
messages
go across town to get gas like
everything you can't buy strawberries
today
you know they'll be they'll be 20 cents
cheaper tomorrow everything was about
fear
and so I I couldn't do anything about it
or didn't think I could do anything
about it
and I just kept telling myself one day
one day I'm gonna be in a position to
change this
and I think that really drives me today
to like
take care of
people not be in that situation again as
long as I got money somebody will make
sure for me yeah as long as I have
influence money as long as I have the
gold look if you have the goal you make
the rules but and that is that has
existed for thousands of years it will
not be a it will never be violated that
is the rule and and I know people say it
sounds terrible I I always looked at
this game like I want to have the gold I
want to make the rules I'll find
somebody that gave up on their dreams
billions of people give up on their
dreams every day you're never going to
think you're not going to fix that
shortage overnight I would encourage
everybody to become more like me so that
at least you get on the other side of
this rainbow and say oh I know what it
looks like over here because most people
never even get why
because because people people ask this
question that you just asked
and and that question is based on a give
up it's based on a surrender to the game
okay should everybody play the game yeah
everybody should play the game should
everybody learn backgammon yes because
you should learn backgammon because it's
a cool game to play should everybody
learn how to make money uh yeah you
should because if you give up before you
do it
you'll never know you'll never know man
and I'm telling you money
like just this concept money won't make
you happy where did that come from
lies and deception
lies and deception yeah yeah because
most people that say money won't make
you happy don't have any money or
they're trying to get your money yeah
and I'm gonna tell you money has made me
happier
as long as you get the right amount of
it you can change my life your money
cannot change my life you can give me a
stack of money as big as you want you
ain't got enough there's nobody on this
stream not one person on this stream a
combined 50 of you cannot change my
financial life it's impossible
but you could change my life your
charity could change my life it could
give us more purpose you could help me
with my Foundation
in your part of the world you could help
me with my legacy you could help my
children when I'm not here she's 30
years old maybe I'm not here and you're
in Singapore you're in Dubai or you're
in Lafayette Louisiana or you're in
Indianapolis and you see her and she
needs some help you can help me
you can help her but you can't help her
if you ain't got anything you don't have
a job an opportunity you don't have
money you worried about your own stuff
you can't even keep your own
refrigerator full how can you help
Sabrina it's impossible for those of you
who feel like he's preaching at you it's
cause you're resisting
the lecture
you're resisting the answers those of
you who are like give me more bro give
me more I need the six pieces it's not
about having the six pieces of data it's
about executing the six pieces of data
so if I didn't care about you guys I
just go on my life and go buy another
piece of real estate tomorrow and then I
do a second deal and a third deal and a
fourth deal and a fifth deal if it was
just about the money okay so we're here
to help you stay here right now stay
here stay present you got to keep making
a decision
okay let me add a piece see Elena's
getting it right now Joe Joe mascali's
getting it Joe nice beard bro damn
incredible where are you where in the UK
are you
in Essex just outside of London I know
where Essex is okay uh you're close
you're close to Saint Hill aren't you
what saint heel no
oh Sussex Oh I thought you said Sussex
okay hey let me ask you something how
often do you have to take care of that
beard
I pretty much stroke it a lot yeah you
stroke yourself a lot huh yeah I got
gunned up but that's pretty much it yeah
but every morning every morning you you
keep working it out don't you 100 rush
it out in the morning yeah definitely
there you go thank you mate thank you
for being here okay now folks what is
your beard that you take care of every
day because I know a lot of you think
man I just can't stay with it promise
you
I'm going to give you a list of things
that you can stay with in fact I want
you to write these things down I want
you to write down the things that you do
every day because a lot of you think you
can't stay with it and it's a lie
write down some things that you do every
day that take zero energy and you do it
every day Joe takes care of his bit
beard he calls it stroking
he doesn't even call it taking care of
the beard okay how many of you put
makeup on every day all you ladies out
there every day you do it okay you do
these things naturally I just want to
recover for you I want to recover for
you your belief in yourself
foreign
it is not true that if you that you have
failed you you are taking care of you
Stewart every day you're taking care of
your eyeballs right now
you're taking care of yourself every day
the problem is and this is what this is
what Brandon's talking about
the problem is
you're not taking care of the things
that can get you up to the top of the
mountain do I have a coach yeah no I do
not have I mean I have my church my
church is my coach yeah yeah so any
anytime
you know anytime I'm like uh you know
some look some people they could get
coaches they don't even have the right
questions to ask like
forget the right answer do you you know
most people don't even have the right
questions sure sure so so uh part of
part of what I do with my church is to
figure out what question I should even
be asking
because most of the time I'm like hey
what's wrong with this well I should
like that's not even what's wrong you
see this financial statement right now
right here everybody has one some of you
are seeing one for the first time in
your life financial statements
everywhere in the world whether I go to
Cincinnati or Singapore they're
identical I go to Dubai or I go to uh
Taipei or I go to Sydney Australia
financial statement the languages are
different the culture is different the
foods are different everybody agree
the colors of the skin might be
different the financial statement is the
same everywhere
and they all start like this okay
there's there's there's this much of it
that's the revenue of the company
typically there's this much revenue and
there's that many expenses
okay which one's more powerful
this is more powerful than that
okay I need to spend 95 percent of my
time on the top part of this you see
where it says Revenue gross sales Less
sales returns and allowances net sales
that little that little piece right
there you can take to Infinity
that you could take the zero and that's
it you can never get it lower than zero
and like if that don't Boggle your mind
if that little simple concept I can take
expenses to zero I can take gross sales
to infinite
how big can I imagine
okay how do I pay for the jet sales
how do I pay for the 19 country trips
sales okay who's going to give me a sale
people the Top Line those top line is
people 95 of your time should be spent
on income and people
people have everything you want
the people that you know do not have
what you want the people that you don't
yet know have everything you dreamed of
so how old are you sir
57 years old the people that love him
and care for him that have taken care of
him that support him have had plenty of
damn time to change his life
he needs to now say okay I've been
looking at the wrong damn place
okay he now needs to meet the people
that can change his life because it's
not his mom his dad his uncle his
grandpa his kids the people that love
you are not going to change the quality
of your life they've had plenty of time
to do that when I met Elena I called my
mom I said I met my wife today
[Music]
she's like have y'all been out yet I
said no she hates my guts
she wants nothing to do with me okay
kind of like I felt about Pete the first
time I met Pete
I told Jared I said I want nothing to do
with him
[Music]
it's a true story
he's like can I get five minutes
[Music]
just might be 15 seconds boom he made an
impression with me first impression is
what's first impression
last Impressions more important than her
first impression most of the people you
meet they're going to have a bad first
impression of you
okay most of the people I meet do not
like me my wife had she did not not like
me she didn't even see me
[Music]
she didn't like I was invisible to her
she couldn't remember what had black
hair brown hair short tall she didn't
remember nothing like she's like huh who
are you I met you last night huh
you know the god to God the guy in the
RV uh-huh so so look no matter what you
do there's gonna be people that don't
know you
right you're going to be humble Elena
did not know me did not want to know me
did not want to get to know me my mom
said Grant if she don't like you it
takes two grand it takes two how many of
your parents told you that before it
takes two you gotta have two people in a
marriage and I told my mom thank you
thank you Mom thank you and I hung up
and I'm like she wrong again
it don't take two folks it takes one
person to make a relationship work
takes one person to make a sale you know
me things
that in my life where nobody wanted to
buy it
okay almost probably probably eighty
percent of everything I've ever sold
with some to someone that didn't want to
buy it
the other 20 wanted to buy something
from me
last thing I'm gonna say it
my idea and our idea to get you here
you you got
you you didn't buy this you understand
that okay don't be saying oh yeah I
bought it no you didn't you got sold
this
okay we sold you on coming here you this
wasn't your idea you didn't call them
say hey I'd like to come down to the 10x
headquarters I'd like to give you guys
money spend a couple days that are
learning
[Music]
challenge together and sign me up for a
lot of other brand as well
no no this was our idea to get you here
[Music]
the same thing is going to happen for
your audience
them wanting to do something with you
you got to decide it takes one person to
make a sale
it never takes a buyer almost never
takes the buyer takes me to walk up and
say this is what we're doing I was
talking to some Wall Street guys and I'm
like dude I I hate these Wall Street
people
and I said they're just I'm just not
accepted there I'm not like them and the
guy looked at me says bro it's because
you're talking to the wrong people he
didn't say bro by the way but he says
it's because Grant he's like Grant
you're not talking to the top of the
food chain
the top of the food chain
is exactly like you that's interesting
they would never judge you they would
never criticize you they would only
admire you they would want to pick up
the bill with you they would think they
were with a brother
he says it's everybody they hired below
him that is threatened by you
they said the reason you don't feel
comfortable talking to these people is
because you're talking to one level
below who you should be talking to and
that level seems like a level above
because it could be a level above where
you're at because but it's a different
game it's a different playing field the
guy looked at me says look bro you're a
Savage and you're a beast you have to
talk to Savages and beasts yeah you're
not you're not built to be a corporate
guy that's not you like the reason you
the reason you're uncomfortable Grant
he's like the guy told me and he's this
guy's way up there he says the reason I
believe you've had problems is because
you've simply been dealing with the
wrong people
and in thinking that you needed those
people
you know and and the reality is you are
those people you're studying I thought I
was Frugal I thought I was a mooch I
thought I was cheap I was told all these
things because in reality tight you know
I could squeeze an eagle off the quarter
people I'd go look at a 200 I still
wanted the price of this stuff I think
it's an apartment of what the price of
something is
um
I would look at the price of something
and if I was not cheap I was
misidentifying what the problem was the
problem for you when you look at it what
you're what you're getting is
can I reproduce that 200 pounds and
you're not sure yet
so you're not sure when you get sure
you'd be like yeah I'll take that I'll
take five of them
and um
and and that is the key the key is to
get so confident in your ability to
reproduce money now the the this
complicates the issue because if you're
in the e-commerce space
you're in a space that literally was
just created overnight like it didn't
even exist what 10 years ago and got hot
here only in the last probably 28 months
or so
so you have the data
you have data that says wait a minute
this space didn't exist which only means
it might not exist in the future
right it could go away as fast as it can
so you have it on board
those birds I was with yesterday they
think everybody it wants to eat them
like they they don't trust anybody they
don't trust their owner they trust no
one and
um that's a good thing to have so that
when you look at it you're like hey is
this business going to be here is this
business going to work is new money
going to come in do I have the systems
in place do I trust my people do I trust
myself this all changed for me with this
real estate stuff so we have I have 13
little businesses uh and then the real
estate the real estate is the one that
can't be stopped there's nothing in the
on planet Earth short of North Korea
going nuclear nothing will stop the
income that's produced by that when you
have that coming in and I'm willing to
work hard every day like you are but I
have this machine going over here six
thousand Apartments seven thousand
Apartments eight thousand ten thousand
pay me every month a couple hundred
bucks
then I'm like let's go on the trip yeah
okay who cares what jet fuel costs
because I got a machine going over here
and that should be the game for
everybody
do great at this
the earned income that the queen taxes
so heavily
and then go over there and find this
passive income that will pay you
regardless of how talented you are how
smart you are how well the video does or
how well the product release does
get that passive income to be more than
the earned income you're going to get
what you go look for
if you're looking for a purple elephant
you'll find one this weekend even though
there's not one on this planet how many
of you can look for a purple elephant
look for one I'll bet you find one if
you look for a 32 unit deal you'll find
a 32 unit deal if you look for the
credit you find the credit you'll find
the debt you'll find the cash you'll
find the deals you'll if you're looking
for a partner you can find a partner if
all you do is keep looking for excuses I
don't have time I don't have money I
can't do it I'm black I'm Brown I'm too
young I'm too old I'm a girl I'm this I
got a job I'm too young how old are you
man
[Music]
and you're 19 years old
it's time and I'm taking you under my
wings
okay come spend two or three weeks in
Offices here in Miami we'll put you up
you cannot you can you can literally
what's it called the attorney you're an
intern with me yeah
all right
[Music]
I'm years old man I need I needed a man
okay her his mom is probably a great mom
she can't be a mom and a day
the better the mom you are the worse the
dad
so I'm a good father I am a terrible
mother
I'm like
we're on the 30th floor yeah I'm a
father I'm a I'm a guy right so I just
it's a different vibe and my mom tried
to be a mom and a dad and she couldn't
and so you be the mom you know I don't
know where your dad is but if I could
anyway and by the way the mom and the
dad can only do so much and then an
uncle needs to accept it
okay
we'll hook you up okay all right guys
let's get back in here we appreciate you
being here I hope you get more stuff
your department and your household has a
financial statement
if you if you look up the word economics
in the dictionary economics means
management of a household and this is
where people go a little fuzzy right now
you could be going fuzzy
what's he talking about I'm talking
about your damn money
just right on here my damn money
that's what finances is it's my money
you know how many have you seen that
little t-shirt I got who's got my money
that that's what this is a professional
baseball player said he was retired he's
a retired professional baseball player
he's like he's in business for himself
now he's like when you said who's got my
money he's like literally changed my
entire business
he's like I was spending time on a bunch
of complicated stuff
and wasn't doing what I knew to do in
baseball in baseball what is if you're a
batter what's the game
get on base that is not hit the ball
it's get on base
you could get hit by the ball
and you'll celebrate yourself
right it's get on base once you get on
base what's the next thing you want to
do
[Music]
you want to advance
okay in finance you need to advance your
finances everybody agreed the way to
advance finances is not to to shrink the
bottom two-thirds of this statement it
is to grow the top line of the statement
same thing for your household your
household needs more income Chris the
police officer if he wants more money he
cannot reduce his expenses as far as he
can raise his income
you can only reduce your expenses to
zero everybody agree
I can only reduce so far
what can I do with income if Chris got
really creative how far could his income
go
it's Unstoppable it's unlimited he can
only no matter how bright he is or how
smart he is a company an individual
household can only take their expenses
solo Apple computer has two 196 billion
dollars in cash today they will borrow
money tomorrow morning debt is good some
debt is good debt and there's not a
wealthy company on this uh Planet not
one wealthy company on the planet earth
that is cash free that does not use debt
I don't want to get out of debt I want
to create wealth and the way to create
wealth is through debt and the debt is
cheap the debt is under three percent
I pay interest only I don't even pay the
mortgage down so basically what I'm
doing is prepaying my mortgage massive
amounts of margins I'm paying down in
the beginning so it stays stable my debt
stays stable and the asset goes up in
value so like a house you see the
problem with a house and you shouldn't
even have this comparison of
conversation because if I buy a house
for let's say the house is average house
about two hundred forty thousand dollars
in America and I put five percent down
you're probably over leverage right
there
why would they give me that loan and the
house doesn't provide any income I want
to check every month I don't want to
check every quarter I want to check
every month I don't want to check 10
years from that dude I want that paper
back today I want to sell to the Goldman
Sachs and the blackstones of the world
you you can't start there but you can
level the game up to play there
oh you guys saying I don't need this and
I don't need that I don't need this and
I don't need that I don't need that oh
my God why you gotta have all that how
can you know what you want
when you ain't never done it
just keep it real man I'm sitting here
on the front of a damn 180 foot yacht
leaving Monaco
telling my buddy Brandon back there I
said bro my whole life
my whole life I have been
guilty of saying I didn't need this or
that without even knowing what this or
that was
I'll tell you how many times I said now
I don't need a yacht
who needs a yacht nobody needs a yacht
I've never been on a yacht man
okay like take a Jacuzzi on this yacht
while you leave other yachts in Monaco
you do this one time and I guarantee
you're gonna start thinking God damn man
how could I give me a yacht you know
what I'm saying I'm just keeping it real
with you this 10x thing makes you think
big makes you act bigger and get you
around some stuff where you're like
maybe I do need a yacht now fortunately
or unfortunately I've given this
experience to my daughter which she will
never ever forget
I hope you guys are unfortunately are
you because when you can't forget it you
can't forget it you're like God dang I'm
gonna go back to that life it's like
flying private you fly private one time
and man you will hate boarding Southwest
Airlines
fantastic man this is how everybody
should live and I'm sharing this with
you guys just so you know man how can
you know what you want when you've never
even seen it been around it nobody's
sharing it with you they're not talking
about how cool it is and good it is
because I know there's a whole bunch of
people in here gonna hate on me because
I'm showing
me and my family living on a yacht for
two weeks in the south of France I know
people gonna hate on me for that why
though why are you hating
on somebody just trying to share a
billion dollars worth of game for free
you understand I'm just telling you
share this with somebody that's always
already tell you I don't need to be rich
I don't need to be married I don't need
to have kids I don't need the vacation
in the world I don't need a car I don't
need you know uh the dream
how would you know
if you've never had it if you've never
experienced it
these are balloons for one my my
daughter's Scarlett okay she didn't know
she needed that but she knew she wanted
it
okay made me feel good about to do it
for her
so look
just remember the next time make an
agreement right now the next time you
say I don't need all that just ask
yourself have you even had that
even know what that smells like on Open
Sea in a Mediterranean to do a trip like
this and bring a bud say hey man I got
you bro
okay to bring my kids my wife on a trip
and not have to worry about the money
every second
I used to take vacations I worried about
the cost of it before the trip while I
was booking the trip during the trip and
definitely worried about it after the
trip
yourself in a situation where you can do
anything with the people that you love
and care for look I'm looking at castles
come on
God bless be great so when we wrote the
10x rule
I mean all books that I write all the
books that I write I write for me I'm
not writing for you okay somebody else
gets something out of it good I write
the book sit down it's a way for me to
like re like hey what am I what what do
I have to do to go to the next place I'm
not trying to sell a book to make money
there's no money in selling a book you
get 15 cents
to sell a book stupid right so Elena's
finishing a book right now now she
realizes how dumb it is
because it's hard
so when we wrote the 10x rule our
advertising budget was almost nothing
almost zero we'll spend 12 plus million
dollars this year in advertising when I
wrote the 10x rule the company was doing
about 600 Grand a year this year we'll
do 150 million bucks so would you spend
12 million dollars thank you would you
spend 12 million dollars
to make 150 million dollars a year
okay the first the first three or four
million dollars is not going to get you
the explosion is probably not going to
happen in Year One
okay you start spending that kind of
money you do need employees
you need people answering the telephone
you need people on websites you need
people building landing pages you need
graphics
okay anybody thinking different right
now anybody right now thinking hey dude
I got a break and I got I got to swell
up here some of you spend more time in
the
gym and sometimes some of you spend too
much time at the movie
what are you doing
I want to spend time on my financial
statement what part of that financial
statement do I want to spend time on
okay
treasury people here Finance people
treasury accountants CFOs raise your
hand if you are congratulations for
being here okay let me see your hand
again if you're CFO treasury Finance
okay good how many of you do not have a
finance person with you here today
dude you need to get those people here
they're holding your company back their
brakes
they sit on breaks we shouldn't spend
that much money is Susan here today
Sherry
okay good Susan's the finance I'm glad
she's not here she'll hear this from my
people okay so Susan is a financial
person and she works in my real estate
division and and once a week we have a
meeting
and yesterday she was in my office and
she's like if we do this and this and
this we're not going to be able to do
this and I said dude dude look look I
didn't ask you for that
you're the finance person
you're not the entrepreneur here
you let me figure out how to pick it and
how to make it work you just report the
numbers tell me if there's any Outlets
keep everything clean keep it ethical
made the business person here
Finance is not business
right so who gave you your your business
advice where are you getting it from I
don't get it from somebody that's
conservative
you understand I'm not going to give it
for somebody that's in conservation mode
conservation is a tone level it is a
tone it was like I want to protect
things
you have kids you don't have kids and
then you have kids does it change you
you immediately go into conservation
okay a woman a woman she's a freak she's
a total freak everybody knows she's a
freak she has a kid
she pulls it back in she's like oh can't
be a freak anymore man Elaine I'm
talking about my wife
total freak as a kid
turns into a Republican
starts dressing nice
I know no no she starts conserving she's
trying to protect you understand
somebody doesn't have any money you give
them a couple million bucks they're
gonna go into conservation mode or
they're going to go broke you have to go
into conservation mode first foreign but
if you stay in conservation mode if
you're taking notes you want to write
this down if you stay in conservation
mode you will lose it all I got my
shades on this morning John you know why
why because my future's so bright
I tried to go without him this morning
but it was like I was being Blinded By
by what was in front of me by the
possibility by the potential of the
potential you know I was I was thinking
this morning John
I was thinking this morning on a serious
note somebody asked me last night hey
what drives you
and uh
I'm like yeah what does drive me for a
moment I didn't have an answer kind of
threw me off a little bit I mean I know
the answer it threw me off a little bit
because I'm like what is driving me now
you know it's different than what was
driving me when I was busted up
and
and then I looked at it I looked at it
and I said oh wow you know what's been
driving me the whole time is the just
the little improvements the possibility
of improvement you know which is really
what potential is
doesn't matter how big your potential is
or because because the true potential of
the individual I don't think is revealed
without success like you gotta have
little successes
to get a little peek of what you can do
I don't think any others actually know
what we can do
and so when you're 25 years old I was 25
I was broke had no money didn't have any
friends my family didn't believe in me
I had no money
when I went from no money in my pocket I
had 50 bucks all of a sudden I was like
wow and by the way I earned that 50
nobody gave it to me I didn't steal it I
didn't rip anybody off I earned it I was
like wow it was a big deal that 50 bucks
was a big big deal then when I learned
how to consistently do that and sort of
discipline myself to not waste the money
blow it on dumb stuff not end up with a
hangover for 50 bucks I know a lot of
people make 50 bucks and end up with a
hangover and that's all they end up with
not even a memory
and and and then I did 500 and then I
did a thousand and then all of a sudden
I started oh wow man maybe this money
thing is important
because it started making me feel a
little bit better about myself and then
the next thing you know I'm going I'm
having meetings with
other people that are thinking about
success and my network has changed a
little bit and now the next thing I know
is my health has changed a little bit
and my sense of self is changing it was
the attainment of the potential in
little increments so for the last 30
years basically what I've done is
working increments little tiny
improvements every day but this is the
most important thing that I found out
if you show up
every day and work on the little
improvements what will happen is along
the way you hear people talk about
setbacks and and and and bad things
happen to them but if you if you keep
showing up every day I promise you in
addition to some setbacks They're Gonna
Come
you're also going to see spikes
and surges
little pops upward just like I said back
but if you're showing up every day with
the right attitude right people right
surroundings reading the right books
getting the right material looking for
little improvements what will happen is
you'll get the spikes and the spurts in
fact you'll get more of those and you
will setbacks and it's the spikes and
the spurts it's that boom that big
growth
even children get this little little
kids have spikes and spurts of growth
okay this is what reveals
the real potential this is what keeps
people really excited about possibility
and what you can do
and that's what drives me today okay
look the increments are great today but
I'm really looking for those spikes I'm
looking for those those surges of growth
financially
Network people connections ideas
I hope you go find those spikes and
spurts but you're not going to get them
you're not going to get a surge without
the daily increments
and that's what drives me today I want
to talk to you today about success all
right I want to I want to how many of
you'd like to have success in your life
okay what does that mean to you though
you're going to either go get it or
somebody else is going to go get it
there's two types of people people that
are going to get what they want and the
life they want
people that don't life is bad for too
many people good for a bunch of people
and great for this many the biggest
problem I had when I was 15 was I was
bored too much I didn't know anything
about potential I knew I had potential
but the biggest reason I was bored is
because I wasn't going after my
potential all the time I challenge you
this summer to only be focused on hey
man what's my potential no matter how
good you play your video game no matter
how good you are in school no matter how
you good you are on the field there's
another place where coach is trying to
push you to that next level and that's
where it gets exciting do you want goals
that are so big so big that every day
you wake up and you're excited and the
reason I wasn't excited when I was your
age was because nobody was telling me
man have some goals man
because if you don't have your own goals
this is what you're going to do you're
going to spend your whole life
making somebody else's dreams come true
this is what you should walk away with
today the Gap the Gap is the difference
between where you are where you sit
right now and what
foreign
we're going to give everybody a copy of
this one it says I am greatness don't
fight it how to be a billionaire I want
to be a billionaire I want to be a
billionaire you know that's all man I
was summing that song I'm like I want to
be a billionaire and a lady came up to
me after this meeting I did this morning
in Los Angeles she says I just want to
be a millionaire I'm like you already
are a millionaire she's like what do you
mean I'm like look everybody's a
millionaire or something everybody is a
millionaire come on how many times have
you had gas at least a million times in
your lifetime right how many times have
you took a breath of air at least a
million times how many times has your
heart beat it your heart beat it that's
not even a word but how many times does
that happen right at least a million
times see most people are millionaires
in many things they're just not like
looking at what they're a millionaire at
being a millionaire is not that
difficult I'm telling you it's not that
difficult look how many people do you
know that are millionaires and excuses
millionaires in being late millionaires
in not making things work how about a
millionaire at failing how about a
millionaire at dreams see how about a
millionaire at thoughts look if you can
be a millionaire that easily in so many
different areas once you just put your
focus down and say hey now I'm going to
be a millionaire at money because that's
what it is it's about Focus what are you
focused on excuses reasons Alibis
justifications being late eating too
much chocolate you think you hadn't had
a million pieces of chocolate chocolate
in your lifetime probably how have you
overeaten a million times do you have a
million calories of consumption in your
lifetime sure million breaths of air
million heartbeats you're a millionaire
already just change the way you're
thinking about it hey now I want to be a
millionaire on money
now I want to now I want to create
enough wealth for myself and my family
so I can actually take care of them
folks that's not a bad thing oh and by
the way you guys that say oh money won't
make you happy look you're just a
millionaire excuses you're a millionaire
at little quotes that mean nothing and
go nowhere what are you going to be a
Millionaire on hey you guys keep asking
me what enough money is how many times I
got to tell you first of all if you're
asking a question you don't have enough
money number two enough money by
definition at least my definition would
be you can take care of everyone you
love everyone all the people your sister
that you forgot about your aunt that
took care of you when you were growing
up maybe a school teacher that helped
you out a bunch is struggling now like
you can help your two kids your wife or
husband
and your parents and beyond that you
know what I'm saying you can reach deep
start helping all the people you love
that would be enough money and still
take care of yourself by the way I know
some of you out there taking care of
somebody else but you don't take care of
yourself so you'd have to be able to
take care of everybody you love all the
people you forgot that you love and the
people that can't take care of
themselves the guy on the street corner
that you're like dude I feel sorry for
this guy I want to help him out you can
take care of all those people and
yourself and I'm not done
okay
when you expire and you're done your
history you can't work anymore can't
produce anymore you're you're expired
you would steal you got enough money to
still take care of the people you love
the things you love the Charities you
love the causes that you believe in
yeah that's what would be enough money
and still not be out by the way
you would have abundance in every way
you would have Wealth Beyond anything
that's destructible
it would last forever and you could
literally change the world
with the money that you produce because
you were committed you were charitable
you cared enough to go big enough
a lot of you guys man y'all just don't
care about enough people that's why you
think so small
[Music]
it's not about the cars and the shades
and the clothes and the watches yeah all
those things are cool and everything but
the real game is can you create enough
wealth
to continue and you can by the way and
it's possible for anyone to do if you
dream big enough it's not possible if
you don't make this big
but if you did think this big
you could think this big if you got
around other people that thought this
big
they'd encourage you to think big and
really live into your full potential
you could create create you could
absolutely 100 starting from zero still
create enough wealth to take care of you
all the people you love all the people
you forgot that you love and even when
you're done you could keep taking care
of people I see 10x branding everywhere
not just in your conferences I feel like
it has become part of your branding what
does 10x represent or 10x 10x was a
discovery I made in 2008 when the
economy crashed I went from having some
money it's a net worth to like 2008 like
literally like I thought I was going to
lose everything we had a baby on the way
I was embarrassed that I'd put my family
in this situation I didn't have anything
to do with the mortgage crisis yet it
pulled everything with it it was like a
you know everybody got affected dude
everybody it did you it didn't matter
who you were so I went and sat in my
office said how did I do this like
anytime I have a problem first thing I
look at after blaming everyone I look at
what did I do the one thing I didn't do
right
was I kept hearing this thing too big to
fail too big to fail and I'm like bro
they're telling you be too big to fail I
was too small I should have scaled I
needed to be bigger my wife said what
are we going to do different next time
and I'm like and when she says what are
we going to do different that means
she's gonna be the cheerleader and I'm
gonna go do it right which is cool I
need that partnership and and I said
next time this happens I will have 10
times the debt 10 times the assets and
10 times the companies today I owe two
billion dollars I don't have three
companies I have uh 17. we have 100
times more people to talk to at least a
hundred times maybe a thousand times a
bigger audience and we're in 25
verticals not not two
so 10x basically is scale you got to get
big you don't have a choice if you want
to survive on this planet without
worrying every second of every day you
got to get big or you gotta get a
partner you got to be with a partner in
this ready to scale you guys want to
take some notes right now I'm gonna
teach you the money game
how to manage money one of the most
important lessons you're going to learn
in your life right now you don't want to
add you want to multiply this is how you
get money all right one you get it now I
need to keep it okay I didn't write save
it what you want to do is you want to
multiply what's your name
King King I like that man okay so look
King uh if when you come back here when
you come back here let's see what's the
date today 28 thank you man man you're
on your game too huh he says I get 100
for that sure man appreciate it what's
your name thank you Vincent my I had an
uncle named Vincent good guy he always
believed in me
me and you this guy this guy this guy
this guy's a Storyteller right here huh
I like that you got some moose bro go
ahead there you go Vincent first part of
this little game right here is you don't
need to make something to get money but
you do need to get in the right room
with the right people that have money if
I didn't have any money could I play
this game with you guys no if I was
broke if I was doing the wrong stuff if
I was out you know drinking and drugging
on the weekends I and I'm losing stuff
and I'm going crazy and I'm then I can
help you because you made it this far in
a video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because because
you are awesome for some incredible Alex
harmosi motivation check the video right
there next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there they just keep going and so to the
same degree you probably do things every
single day that you should not be doing
and so what I want to introduce to you
is a concept of the anti-routine as the
most productive routine that is humanly
possible for you